bien nous allons démarrer avec
Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel Attal nous
rejoindra dans quelques minutes
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
reporteur général mes chers collègues
donc nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
cet après-midi monsieur le ministre
Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel Attal qui
viennent nous présenter aussi bien le
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 que
le projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années
2023 à 2027 deux textes délibérés ce
matin en Conseil des ministres
nous recevons mercredi matin le
président du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques sur l'avis du Haut Conseil
relatif à ces deux textes ainsi qu'aux
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023
le projet de loi de finance est le
premier texte qui applique la réforme de
la loi organique relative au loi de
finance promulguer le 28 décembre 2021
en particulier certains articles
renforcent l'information du Parlement
vous le savez sur les crédits et sur la
trajectoire plus réelle et la
répartition des articles entre première
et seconde partie qui est je crois
clarifié
ce budget constitue aussi
la première étape de mise en oeuvre de
la future loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui prévoit dans le
texte proposé par le gouvernement retour
du solde public à moins de virgule 9% du
PIB en 2027 et fixe des orientations
pour l'évolution des crédits du budget
général mais aussi pour ceux des
collectivités territoriales et des
administrations de sécurité sociale
ces deux textes sont soumis alors c'est
un peu l'habitude mais quand même cette
année de manière très forte soumis à de
nombreuses incertitudes liés à
l'évolution de la situation
internationale et à ses effets sur les
coûts de l'énergie et l'inflation mais
aussi à l'évolution du cadre européen
des finances publiques de nouvelles
règles pouvant être établies au cours de
la mise en œuvre de la loi de
programmation
même si vous avez fait précéder ce dépôt
d'une phase de consultation originale
dite les dialogues de Bercy auxquels
certains d'entre nous ont pu participer
nos collègues auront certainement de
nombreuses questions à vous poser sur
ces deux textes je vous laisse donc la
parole pour un propos liminaire avant
d'avenir à mes questions à celle du
rapporteur général et de l'ensemble des
sénateurs membres de la commission des
finances je vous rappelle que cette
audition monsieur les ministres est
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat je vais donner la parole tout de
suite à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver avec
le ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal pour vous présenter ce premier
budget du nouveau quinquennat qui est
aussi je le rappelle le 6e de notre
majorité
l'objectif de ce budget c'est de tenir
l'équilibre entre la protection de nos
compatriotes et de nos entreprises face
à l'inflation et le nécessaire
rétablissement des finances publiques
qui doit nous amener à 3% de déficits
publics en 2027 sous les 3% de déficit
public tout cela dans une période où
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président les incertitudes n'ont jamais
été aussi grande impact de la guerre en
Ukraine sur les prix de l'énergie
difficultés économiques de nos
principaux partenaires économiques les
États-Unis la Chine avec le covid
l'Allemagne et incertitude politique au
sein de la zone euro avec les dernières
échéances qui viennent de se dérouler
dans ce contexte je tiens à rappeler la
très bonne résistance de l'économie
française
2,7% de croissance prévue pour 2022 là
où les meilleures analystes nous
promettaient pas plus de 2,3% des
créations d'emplois qui restent
dynamiques une consommation des ménages
qui se maintient et un investissement
des entreprises qui restent solides tout
cela nous conduit à maintenir une
prévision de croissance positive à 1%
pour 2023
dans ce contexte la priorité va
évidemment à la lutte contre l'inflation
l'inflation continuera de rester à
niveau élevé dans les mois qui viennent
de l'ordre de 6% avant de revenir autour
de 4% dans le courant de l'année 2023
ces chiffres justifient pleinement la
protection que nous apportons au ménage
la protection que nous voulons apporter
aux entreprises qui sinon commenceraient
à baisser leur production voire à la
délocaliser et la protection que nous
apportons aux collectivités locales
s'agissant des ménages nous avons adopté
une stratégie économique singulière dans
la zone euro qui a consisté à protéger
dès l'automne 2021 contre l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie nous aurons gelé
les prix du gaz plafonner les prix de
l'électricité à 4%, et nous avons donc
contenu l'inflation à niveau qui est le
plus faible de tous les pays de la zone
euro
nous allons maintenir ce bouclier tout
en l'adaptant progressivement en faisant
passer des Hauses de tarifs de 15% sur
les prix du gaz et les prix de
l'électricité au début de l'année 2023
contre plus de 100%, si nous suivions
les prix du marché et plus de 100% ce
serait évidemment intolérable nous
préférons protéger plutôt que de devoir
corriger comme on fait un nombre d'États
européens en raison des difficultés
sociales
le coût de ce bouclier de 16 milliards
d'euros qui sont inscrits dans le budget
2023 11 milliards d'euros pour le
bouclier gaz 5 milliards d'euros pour le
bouclier électricité je rappelle que
c'est un coup net le coût brut est
évidemment beaucoup plus élevé mais il
faut déduire de ce coup brut les prêts
de 20 milliards d'euros que nous
rapporte le prélèvement sur les
énergéticiens et sur la rente
énergétique
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises que nous n'étions pas
favorables à des taxes exceptionnelles
sur les super profiques et en réalité
sont des taxes ordinaires et permanentes
sur tous les profits toutes les
entreprises en revanche nous voulons
récupérer la rente des énergéticiens
c'est ce que nous faisons et c'est ce
que nous permet de financer aujourd'hui
le bouclier énergétique nous protégeons
également nos compatriotes en faisant le
choix du travail qui paye nous avons
décidé de revaloriser le barème de l'IR
du montant de l'inflation 5,4% ce qui
aboutit un résultat très simple nous
évitons à tous ceux qui sont soumis à
l'impôt sur le revenu de payer plus
d'impôts
même si leur salaire augmente le revenu
disponible après un pot restera le même
c'est bien l'objectif de notre politique
économique préserver le travail
faire en sorte que le travail permet de
vivre dignement et ne pas avoir un impôt
qui augmente de manière asymétrique au
fur et à mesure que vous revenus
augmentent c'est un choix de politique
économique qui me paraît essentiel pour
protéger nos compatriotes qui
travaillent contre l'inflation et en
particulier nos compatriotes des classes
moyennes nous voulons aussi protéger des
entreprises et chacun voit bien sur son
territoire à quel point aujourd'hui
l'arrivée des factures énergétiques sur
le bureau des chefs d'entreprise crée de
la crainte de l'inquiétude et beaucoup
d'interrogations
nous avons donc maintenu un tarif régulé
pour toutes les très petites entreprises
chiffre d'affaires inférieures à moins
de millions d'euros et moins de 10
salariés qui bénéficieront de hausse
contenues à 15% et qui garderont le
tarif régulé pour toutes les autres nous
avons fait des demandes de la Commission
Européenne j'ai eu margalvesguer
longuement au téléphone la semaine
dernière pour avoir des critères plus
simples et des aides plus massives pour
les entreprises qui sont exposées à la
concurrence internationale et qui ont
des tarifs d'énergie qui flambent plus
simple ça veut dire que le critère de 3%
de consommation énergétique dans le
chiffre d'affaires peut être adapté pour
qu'il ne soit pas calculé sur 2021 mais
bien sur l'année de référence 2022 ou
l'année prochaine 2023 ce que vous avez
beaucoup d'entreprises qui peuvent être
des verreries des tours de séchage de
lait des entreprises du carton des
entreprises de l'imprimerie qui ont une
part de l'énergie dans leur chiffre
d'affaires qui représentait avant la
crise ou 2% elles sont pas éligibles et
à cause de la flambée ces prix
représentent 4,5% et ne comprennent pas
pourquoi elles ne sont pas éligibles et
donc indispensables de contemporainer
ces aides deuxième chose nous avons dit
à quel point le critère débite d'un
négatif était un critère absurde un
débit d'un négatif sur trois mois c'est
une entreprise industrielle qui est
morte
je connais pas beaucoup d'entreprises
industrielles qui peuvent supporter un
débit d'annégatif sur trois mois donc
nous avons demandé que ce soit ramené à
une baisse de bénéfices sur un mois
enfin j'ai demandé le doublement de ces
aides de 25 à 50 millions d'euros et de
50 à 100 millions d'euros doubler le
seuil et le plafond de ces aides d'État
que nous pourrions apporter aux
entreprises de façon à garantir que
aucune entreprise industrielle de mettre
la clé sous la porte à cause de la
flambée des prix de l'énergie nous avons
d'ores et déjà obtenu je peux vous le
dire que la révision de ce cadre des
êtres d'État n'interviennent pas au 1er
janvier 2023 ce qui aurait été beaucoup
trop tard et pas du tout raccord avec ce
qu'est la réalité des entreprises en
France mais dès le mois d'octobre de
cette année c'est-à-dire d'ici quelques
jours de façon à ce que les entreprises
puissent bénéficier de ces aides tout de
suite au moment où elle signe leur
contrat avec leurs fournisseurs
d'énergie
enfin nous aidons les collectivités
locales nous intéressent au premier chef
avec un fond de 430 millions d'euros qui
était mis en place avec votre aide et
vos conseils lors du PLF 2022 Gabriel
Attal pourra revenir la dessus
notre objectif est également de
transformer notre économie pour rétablir
nos finances publiques et garantir la
baisse la dette publique au moment où
les taux d'intérêt augmentent et la
réduction du déficit pour revenir sous
les 3% de déficit pour cela nous gardons
la même stratégie qui repose sur une
réduction des dépenses le soutien à la
croissance et les réformes de structure
s'agissant des réductions de dépens je
veux redire que nous sommes sortis du
quoiqu'il en coûte que le quoiqu'il en
coûte était approprié pour lutter contre
les conséquences du covid ou la
récession dépassée des 7%, nous
risquions des vagues de faillite par
dizaines de milliers une explosion du
chômage de quoi qu'il en coûte serait
une faute économique face à l'inflation
et ne ferait qu'alimenter l'inflation
faut donc passer à des dispositifs
ciblés comme nous l'avons fait et mettre
fin à tous les dispositifs de soutien
transversaux qui avaient pu avoir cours
pendant la crise du covid je note
d'ailleurs que les mêmes qui critiquent
le monde d'ambition du budget pour 2023
sont les mêmes moments réclamés le
maintien de soutien à toutes les
entreprises à tout moment quelle que
soit les circonstances donc je demande
un peu de cohérence dans les positions
des uns des autres et je ne vise pas ici
les sénatrices et les notes qui sont
présents mais d'autres commentaires qui
ont pu être fait sur le budget 2023
c'est un peu commode de dire au grand
public que le budget n'est pas assez
ambitieux sur la gestion des pensées
de l'Économie des Finances réclamer des
aides transversales et général pour
toutes les entreprises
le deuxième élément c'est
poursuivre avec une croissance forte ce
qui suppose de continuer à soutenir la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et la
politique de l'offre c'est ce qui nous a
amené à maintenir la suppression de la
CVE que nous ferons en deux temps pour
faire preuve d'esprit de responsabilité
4 milliards 2023 4 milliards en 2024
mais où nous proposons d'inscrire la
trajectoire de suppression de la CVAE
dans le budget 2023 de façon à donner
toutes les garanties au chef
d'entreprise notamment industrielles sur
la suppression de la CVA la croissance
est aussi l'innovation nous inscrirons
donc 6 milliards d'euros d'engagement au
titre de France 2030 dans le budget 2023
enfin il n'y a pas de stratégie crédible
de restauration des finances publiques
sans engager les réformes de structure
il faut réduire les dépenses il faut
soutenir la croissance parce que le
plein d'emploi est encore la meilleure
réponse qui soit aux difficultés de
finance publique de la France mais il
faut également engager des réformes de
structure
l'assurance chômage d'abord dans un pays
où il y a près de 400 000 personnes qui
cherchent les bras de la main d'oeuvre
qui ne la trouve pas qu'elles sont mis
d'emplois donc pourvu me paraît légitime
de durcir des règles de l'assurance
chômage c'est ce que nous allons faire
il me paraît également nécessaire je le
redis de décider une réforme des
retraites qui puisse entrer en vigueur à
l'été 2023 comme le président de la
République l'a indiqué c'est ce qui nous
permettra de financer notre modèle de
protection sociale sans augmenter les
impôts c'est ce qui me permettra de
maintenir la solidarité française sans
augmenter les impôts et de garantir la
prospérité la nation française quand je
regarde aujourd'hui ce qui fait la
différence entre la France et les autres
nations développées la France réussit
partout mène un volume global de travail
insuffisant et là notamment un taux
d'emploi des plus de 55 ans qui est un
des plus faibles des pays développés
près de 20 points de moins que ce qui
existe en Allemagne où il y a plus de
70% des personnes de plus de 55 ans qui
travaillent c'est une perte de
compétences c'est une perte de
savoir-faire c'est une perte
d'expérience c'est une perte de
prospérité pour notre pays il est
nécessaire de mettre en œuvre une
réforme des retraites pour financer la
solidarité française notre modèle de
protection sociale et garantir la
prospérité des générations qui viennent
ce budget enfin marque notre
détermination a poursuivre
l'accélération de la transition
écologique alors je reconnais très
honnêtement que comme nous consacrons
beaucoup de moyens sur le bouclier du
gaz cela a un impact aussi sur la
qualité du budget vert et que nous
pouvons que nous devons faire mieux dans
les mois qui viennent je veux simplement
noter un certain nombre d'avancées
importantes le budget de ma prime rénov
qui passe de 2,5 milliards d'euros et
1,3 milliards d'euros pour le
verdissement du parc automobile et le
1,5 milliards d'euros du fond annoncé
par la première ministre pour
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales dans cette transition
climatique enfin je signale une décision
politique majeure la fin de toute
garantie export pour toutes les énergies
fossiles c'est la première fois que la
France renonce accorder quelques
garanties export que choix un projet
fossile au stade de l'exploration du
raffinage ou du transport je pense que
cela marque un virage très important en
matière de transition climatique enfin
ce budget je le redis reste conforme aux
engagements pris en matière de finance
publique les dépenses de l'État
baiseront de 0,2 % en volume par rapport
à la loi de finance rectificative 2022
avec un objectif avoir une augmentation
des dépenses en volume toute
administration confondue de 0,6 sur la
durée du quinquennat je rappelle que
dans les 10 dernières années passées
c'était au-dessus de 1%
et que dans les 20 dernières années
c'était au dessus de
2%. donc progressivement nous arrivons à
réduire la part de la dépense publique
dans la richesse nationale et nous
ralentissons l'accroissement en volume
la dépense publique on peut là aussi
toujours faire mieux toutes les
propositions de réduction indépendance
qui pourront être faites par les
sénatrice et pas les sénateurs seront
reçues avec le plus grand intérêt par le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Gabriel attaque délégué chargé des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général en complément de ce
qui est indiqué à Bruno Le Maire je
dirais que face aux aléas qui sont
devant nous et auxquels nous sommes
confrontés à géopolitique économique des
très difficiles de prévoir ce que sera
l'avenir d'avoir une boule de cristal en
revanche nous avons une boussole qui est
la protection de nos concitoyens et le
budget qu'on présente est un budget de
protection c'est la protection du
pouvoir d'achat avec le bouclier
tarifaire qui a été rappelé par Bruno Le
Maire 16 milliards en net pour 2023 qui
vont nous permettre notamment de
maintenir à de contenir à 15% la hausse
de la facture d'électricité et de gaz
sinon ça serait 120 ou 140%. je pense à
la mesure de revalorisation du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu j'ai entendu des
déclarations qui indiquaient oui mais ça
s'est toujours fait de manière quasi
automatique d'abord il y a des années où
le barème de l'impôt sur le revenu n'a
pas été revalorisé avec l'inflation donc
ça relève toujours d'un choix du
gouvernement et ensuite quand on est
face à une telle inflation la question
peut se poser en l'occurrence là
l'évaluation c'est 6,4 milliards d'euros
lié à cette revalorisation du barème
c'est 6,4 milliards d'euros d'impôts qui
ne seront pas pris au français alors
qu'ils le serait si nous ne revalorisons
pas le barème c'est important de le
noter la protection c'est évidemment
aussi la poursuite de notre action en
faveur de l'emploi on a le taux de
chômage le plus bas depuis 15 ans on
veut poursuivre de ce point de vue là en
continuant à investir notamment pour
l'apprentissage et atteindre le million
d'apprentis conformément à l'objectif
fixé par le président de la République
ce qui explique notamment la hausse très
importante de plus de 6 milliards
d'euros des crédits du ministère du
Travail c'est aussi l'enjeu de la hausse
des crédits du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale puisque la formation ça
démarre très tôt et donc 3 milliards 700
millions d'euros de hausse pour le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale qui
financeront notamment la revalorisation
des salaires des enseignants il y a un
milliard 8 d'impact du point d'indice
près d'un milliard d'euros en plus pour
revaloriser les enseignants et donc
tenir l'engagement du président de la
République 10% de hausse pour tout le
monde pas un seul enseignant payé moins
de 2000 euros net par mois à la rentrée
2023 et ensuite on prépare d'autres
étages de revalorisation qui eux seront
conditionnés à des nouvelles missions
pour les enseignants protéger les
Français c'est la poursuite du
réarmement de nos fonctions régaliennes
plus 3 milliards d'euros pour le
ministère de la Défense conformément aux
engagements de la loi d'orientation et
de programmation de la loi de
programmation militaire un milliard 400
millions d'euros en plus pour le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est conforme
à la trajectoire fixée par la loop me et
je citerai aussi le renforcement massif
du budget du ministère de la Justice
plus 8% pour la troisième année
consécutif c'est historique je rappelle
que le budget du ministère de la justice
aura augmenté entre le début et la fin
du quinquennat précédent de 33% et donc
on poursuit l'augmentation massive du
budget du ministère de la Justice
protéger les Français c'est évidemment
agir pour protéger la planète et
là-dessus Bruno Le Maire a rappelé les
éléments je n'y reviens pas et protéger
les Français c'est aussi protéger nos
comptes publics nous sommes passés du
quoi qu'il en coûte ou combien ça coûte
un euro dépensé doit être un euro
raisonné évalué immédiatement utile à la
protection des Français nous avons fixé
dans le cadre du programme de stabilité
on en a des battu ici cet été une
trajectoire de maîtrise de la dépense
publique qui est la plus ambitieuse
depuis 20 ans sur la durée du
quinquennat la dépense de l'État
baissera de 0,4% en volume en moyenne
annuel celle des collectivités locales
de 0,5% des dépenses de santé
continueront à augmenter compris en
volume c'est un choix politique que nous
faisons notamment pour soutenir
l'hôpital et on voit ce matérialiser
cette trajectoire dès le PLF 2023
puisque la part des dépenses publiques
dans le PIB recul on passe de 57,6% à
56,6%. elle atteindra en 2027 53,8%
vous voyez qu'il y a un effort un effort
massif le cœur de notre stratégie de
finance publique reste la création de
valeur et l'emploi l'amélioration du
taux d'emploi comme la rappeler Bruno Le
Maire qui nous permet d'améliorer nos
recettes et de faire baisser un certain
nombre de dépenses de réparation il y a
aussi une maîtrise de la progression des
dépenses je terminerai avec un point de
méthode pour dire que ce sont tenus
effectivement les dialogues de Bercy
qu'un certain nombre de sénatrices et de
sénateurs y ont participé je les en
remercie je crois que de la vie générale
ces dialogues ont été utiles
pour transmettre un certain nombre
d'informations en amont de la
présentation des textes financiers au
parlementaires ils ont aussi été utiles
pour le gouvernement puisque nous avons
retenu un certain nombre de propositions
qui ont été émises dans le cadre des
dialogues de Bercy nous avons suspendu
nous l'avons annoncé l'actualisation des
valeurs locatives qui devaient
intervenir l'an prochain puisque
l'ensemble des participants des
dialogues de Bercy nous ont fait état de
remonter extrêmement inquiets sur
l'impact en termes d'augmentation de la
fiscalité sur les commerces de
centre-ville et de baisse de la
fiscalité sur les hypermarchés de
périphérie ce qui est pas totalement le
coeur de notre stratégie puisqu'on veut
au contraire revêtualiser les centres
urbains nous avons et je l'ai annoncé
tout à l'heure au Comité des finances
locales pris la décision d'abonder les
dotations de solidarité urbaines et
dotation de solidarité rurales l'an
prochain de 210 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir garantir la stabilité de la part
forfaitaire de la DGF parce que vous
savez que depuis 2017 on avait
sanctuarisé globalement l'enveloppe de
la DGF après les années de couple sous
le quinquennat de François Hollande mais
quand bien
[Musique]
en direction des propriétaires
forestiers nous avons décidé nous
présenterons un amendement puisque ça
n'est pas ce qui était prévu selon la
trajectoire depuis plusieurs années de
sanctuariser les effectifs de l'ONF vous
savez qui ont été réduits ces dernières
années qui devaient encore l'être nous
ajoutons un amendement pour sanctuariser
les effectifs de l'ONF ça fait aussi
suite au dialogue de Bercy il y a eu des
propositions qui ont été faites pour
qu'on améliore l'évaluation de la
qualité de la dépense publique nous
avons ajouté à la loi de programmation
des finances publiques une disposition
qui sera enrichie dans les débats
parlementaires pour établir une liste de
dépenses publiques dont le gouvernement
l'état aura l'obligation d'évaluer la
qualité en débat avec les parlementaires
à l'avenir bref la liste n'est pas
exhaustive mais elle témoigne d'une
chose c'est qu'on a le droit de ne pas
être d'accord surtout c'est même ça en
démocratie mais que ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne peut discuter de rien et je
pense que ces dialogues ont été utiles
et j'espère que les dialogues et le
travail que nous aurons dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent le
sera tout autant au service de nos
concitoyens
merci monsieur le ministre
je vais donner la parole bien sûr au
rapporteur général mais peut-être vous
savez
dans ce débat budgétaire j'aurais
presque envie de parler de mineur
j'aurais des tas de sujets à aborder
alors mes chers collègues soyez rassuré
je le ferai pas mais
je vais quand même en garder une quoi un
petit sujet parce que les dialogues de
Bercy permettent effectivement c'était
je le confirme
utile sur un plan d'abord on a gagné du
temps c'est à dire qu'on est en avance
de phase et le débat déjà budgétaire a
déjà eu lieu avec des échanges certes
avec le bureau de la côte des murs de
commission mais aussi à travers la
presse tout le monde a pu se saisir des
sujets qui étaient sur la table donc
effectivement de ce point de vue là nous
avons gagné du temps
quelques points ont pu être relevés par
vous et trouver des solutions c'est
toujours des bonnes choses mais quand
même sur quelques points essentiels vous
l'avez dit
comment dire on reste sur la copie
d'origine alors
il y a un point particulièrement vous le
savez donc comment dire je vais pas
quand même vous priver de ce plaisir de
m'entendre une nouvelle fois sur la
question de la suppression des impôts de
production et notamment de la CVAE alors
je voudrais il y a plusieurs façons de
le traiter je vais laisser au débat sur
les collectivités locales la question de
la suppression de c.ae et de la façon
dont elle sera remplacée
ou pas autrement en tout cas au niveau
des collectivités locales je vais pas
venir sur ce point à l'instant mais je
voudrais revenir
sur la prévision de croissance d'un mot
que vous évaluez à 1% en 2023 je ne vais
pas la contester personnellement parce
que bon on sait bien qu'il y a des
évaluations très différentes entre -05
et 1 bon mais il me paraît pas une
logique que celui qui mène la politique
économique en tout cas dans notre pays
soit optimiste et donc ils prennent
plutôt le haut de de la fourchette si je
puis dire avec
1%, qu'est-ce qu'on dirait d'un ministre
qui lui-même annoncerait éventuellement
-05 ou des choses comme ça ça aurait
peut-être un caractère presque
auto-réalisateur après donc je crois
qu'il faut toujours que vous d'une
certaine façon quelque
il faut qu'il inspire de la confiance et
de la conscience dans l'avenir donc je
ne le discute pas mais la confiance ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne comment dire
qu'on ne prévoit pas le pire je suis sûr
que vous devez le prévoir or si on fait
0,3 sens ce qui peut être imaginaire
après tout c'est jamais que 15 milliards
aujourd'hui chers collègues ça va ça
vient mais 15 milliards de plus qu'il
faut trouver
et donc je trouve je le redis pour la
énième fois je trouve que dans ces
périodes difficiles vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous-même vous avez introduit
le sujet comme cela c'est une période
économique difficile
dans une période de la croissance n'est
pas assurée même si elle est évidemment
souhaitée et souhaitable et bien se
priver de recettes de l'État n'est pas
une bonne chose alors si c'était Claude
Ronald qui le dit je le dis depuis des
années bon
quoi de neuf mais
je vois que le premier président de la
Cour des comptes je vois que le
gouverneur de la Banque de France je
vois que de nombreuses économistes y
compris des économies d'ailleurs qu'on a
reçu ici et qui était économiste assez
proche de votre vision économique
discute ce point alors vous me direz
c'est plus 8 milliards c'est 4 et 4 bon
ça veut dire ça veut donc dire que c'est
8 milliards pèses vous voyez dans le
côté budgétaire puisque vous êtes obligé
de le réduire à 4 et puis je note aussi
que quand même ceux qui en ont été
comment dire les artisans c'est qu'on
demandait à ce qui est cette baisse se
manifeste aujourd'hui pour protester
avec énergie sur le fait que vous
divisiez par deux
cette baisse des impôts de production
alors je trouve ça quand même fort de
café d'abord vous êtes pas récompensé
bar quand même parce que vous souhaitez
on vous dit passer du 8 milliards 4
milliards le signal n'est plus clair en
vous explique que il y a plus l'effet de
choc quasiment bon donc on baisse ça et
moi j'ai envie de la réponse voyez-vous
à ces braves gens et que si ça sert plus
à rien autant passer à zéro
vous voyez c'est simple et moi je trouve
monsieur le ministre que vous entendriez
leur voix en leur disant
qu'effectivement un choc à 4 milliards
c'est pas un choc et donc c'est zéro
certains économies sur l'ont dit comme
ça alors pas pour qu'ils sont d'accord
avec vous c'est pas mon cas sur l'idée
que la baisse des impôts de production
pourrait être utile aux entreprises etc
mais ils disent renvoyons le à 2027 et
bien au moins ça c'est clair renvoyons
le 2027 et si je devais dire autre chose
encore renvoyons également la dernière
phase là des impôts pour les gens qui
ont les plus hauts revenus en France
ça fait encore 3 milliards tout ça nous
sauve 11 milliards et si par
extraordinaire il y avait pas une
croissance d'un point mais de zéro mais
voilà on a trouvé les sommes sans avoir
à aller les chercher sur les retraites
où je ne sais où voilà ça me paraît être
une bonne question donc
je l'ai prise et vous m'y répondrai si
vous le voulez bien
tout à l'heure et je passe la parole au
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur les ministres c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous accueillir d'autant que
là on a la chance d'avoir les deux
ministres donc je vous le redis comme
j'ai l'occasion de le dire dans le temps
de dialogue des dialogues de Bercy enfin
au Sénat on apprécie
on est bien dans un nouveau quinquennat
et j'y vois une certaine manière un
petit changement de méthode moi je vais
je vais revenir sur la question de la
croissance j'ai pas la lecture forcément
je suis pas pessimiste mais j'ai pas
forcément la lecture aussi optimiste que
celle du président
et en fait j'ai une première question
puisque finalement par rapport à
aux économistes
ou globalement on est plutôt autour de
prévisions d'une stagnation
ou d'une croissance plutôt proche de
zéro
qu'est-ce qui justifie finalement votre
optimisme parce que on voit bien que
appartement on est sur le PDF 2023 et la
LPFP ça peut changer par rapport à la
trajectoire sur le quinquennat qui
s'ouvre donc j'aurais besoin de de mieux
comprendre et en tous les cas de cerner
les raisons qui vous ont qui vous
conduisent à cette optimisme dont on
pourrait si malheureusement la
croissance n'était pas aussi favorable
ensuite payé pendant un certain temps le
je dirais le scénario que vous avez
retenu le scénario m'a cru économique
deuxième sujet j'entends la volonté de
faire des efforts sur les dépenses
publiques mais le Haut Conseil
d'ailleurs ne s'y trompe pas puisqu'il
constate
en fait en excluant les mesures prises
au regard de la crise sanitaire de la
hausse de l'inflation et de la crise de
l'énergie donc c'est pas rien
que la dépense en volume
d'après vous prévisions croix de 1% sur
l'année
qui s'ouvre donc finalement
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu dans
vos propos moi je plus un pour cent ça
fait pas une baisse
j'ai entendu que ça baisserait à la fin
du quinquennat excusez-moi mais chat
échaudé craint l'eau froide donc j'aurai
là encore besoin que vous nous expliquer
comment il y aurait une forme de
retournement de conjoncture qui vous
amènerait à viser juste sur cette baisse
de la dépense publique donc
personnellement je m'inquiète je sais
même c'est même pas du combien ça coûte
monsieur le ministre je pense d'abord
que ça coûte cher et que le diagnostic
doit être partagé pour qu'éventuellement
le plan d'action du gouvernement puisse
être accepté troisième sujet sur
qui touche les collectivités locales sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques parce que finalement vous vous
y remplacer les dépenses pilotables
parce que par un PDE or qui est pas un
plan de déplacement des entreprises qui
est le périmètre des dépenses de l'État
mais avec un petit problème il inclut
cette fois-ci les prélèvements sur
recettes à destination de l'Union
européenne et aux collectivités
territoriales en fait vous renversez les
sabliers la fois précédente dans le
premier quinquennat du point de
République vous aviez exclu les
collectivités locales et là vous les
remettez dans la trajectoire moi je vous
dis donc je nous alerte et en tous les
cas je vous alerte et vous interroge
qu'est-ce qui vous conduit à vouloir
comme ça contraindre les collectivités
territoriales
vous savez très bien puisque l'un et
l'autre vous avez été sur les bancs
notamment de l'assemblée que les
collectivités locales ont une importance
dans l'investissement public et dans les
règles budgétaires
auxquelles elles doivent répondre et
obéir qui ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes que celles de l'État quatrième et
avant dernier point
j'ai entendu parler de la transition
écologique je dois vous dire que j'ai
écouté vos propos Alain à l'autre ont
été très bref
et pour tout vous dire il m'inquiète
j'avais l'occasion de vous expliquer
dans les mandats précédents dans les
années dernière que ce que vous
qualifiez de budget vert était plutôt de
la peinture à l'eau ou un vernis
je confirme d'ailleurs que vous avez
besoin de faire venir l'annoncenne
Valérie Masson Delmotte pour faire
prendre conscience semble-t-il au
gouvernement des enjeux climatiques donc
c'est bien c'est pas parce qu'elle est
l'ancienne que je le dis mais c'est bien
mais je pense que ça ne suffit pas et le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal vient de dire on a parlé tout à
l'heure
de l'enjeu écologique je vous le dis
j'ai trouvé que le balayé de ce seul mot
ne suffit pas je pense que on a une
prise de conscience d'une toute autre
ampleur à prendre
parce que ça va concerner
nos sociétés et parce qu'il va falloir y
mettre de l'intelligence et des moyens
et je pense qu'on a déjà perdu beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et que donc il va
falloir vraiment changer de logiciel et
là pour tout vous dire quand je regarde
les crédits de paiement comment tout ça
va fonctionner et puis ce que vous avez
quand même parler d'un fond vert dans
lequel les collectivités locales
seraient associées alors ça je ne peux
que m'en réjouir parce que si on peut
pour une première fois sur ces sujets
articulés tout le cas le mieux possible
et les actions pour faire en sorte
qu'elle soit productive vous avez
finalement le meilleur contre exemple de
ce qui ne va pas c'est ma prime rénove
un objectif de 8000 pour faire 2000
excusez-moi je le dis comme je le pense
c'est nul
donc évidemment il faut progresser je
pense qu'on va y arriver mais dites-nous
peut-être comment vous voyez les choses
enfin un dernier élément sur la cbae
[Musique]
voilà c'est peut-être pour y réfléchir
donc sur cette cbae moi j'ai j'ai envie
de dire j'ai un problème de là de forme
puisque que ce soit fait en deux ans oui
on l'avait demandé qui est je dirais la
prise en compte de l'intérêt pour les
collectivités
qui ont des compétences de rester
finalement intéressé à l'accueil
d'activité économiques oui mais par
contre vous parlez là encore d'un fond
de ressources on n'a pas un mot à ce
stade sur la gouvernance du fond comment
les élus vont être associés est-ce que
les parlementaires seront aussi dans le
sur le sujet de la critères de
répartition autant vous dire je
comprends pas la méthode vous allez
proposer de concerter après
avoir finalement une décision qui vient
un peu d'en haut je trouve que c'est sur
le sujet de la richesse de la de
l'activité économique je trouve que vous
êtes à contre emplois c'est me
semble-t-il dans la culture qui est la
première ministre a proposé qui est une
culture de compromis j'aurais préféré en
terme de méthode que vous élaboriez un
travail en lien avec les collectivités
de leur représentants pour ensuite
proposer quelque chose pour lequel ici
au Parlement un accord ou un adouement
vient plus naturellement
quelques réponses au reportage
éventuellement à moi-même
mais à tous ces nuire tout honneur je
vais commencer par le président
et je vais reprendre vos mots
pour commencer par
vos dernières remarques sur le Medef qui
trouve que notre budget manque
d'ambition vous dites que c'est fort de
café
je trouve aussi que c'est fort de café
je trouve que c'est fort de café quand
on nous reproche de faire la suppression
de la CVE en deux fois alors que nous le
faisons pour tenir compte la situation
des finances publiques
et que je pense que personne ne peut
remettre en cause la parole du
gouvernement la majorité ou du président
de la République sur la baisse des
impôts nous avions promis la baisse de
l'impôt sur ces sociétés de 33,3 à
25%, c'est fait nous avions promis un
prélèvement forfaitaire unique à 30%
c'est fait nous avions promis de baisser
les impôts de production pour la
première fois depuis 20 ans c'est fait
pour 10 milliards d'euros donc je pense
que personne ne peut douter de notre
détermination à tenir notre ligne c'est
fort aussi de café puisque on nous
demande moins de dépenses publiques
et plus de soutien pour les entreprises
je crois qu'il ne serait pas mauvais de
faire preuve d'un peu de cohérence et
surtout de garder un esprit constructif
un moment où l'économie française est
confrontée à des défis considérables
pour ce qui nous concerne en tout cas
nous tenons notre ligne politique de
l'offre baisse des impôts de production
pour soutenir
l'outil productif français et
rétablissement du compte public cela
témoigne au contraire de notre ambition
économique pour le pays
s'agissant de la suppression de la CVA
d'abord pourquoi est-ce que nous le
faisons
on s'est pas réveillé un matin en se
disant tiens on va supprimer la CVL cela
fait plus de 5 ans maintenant que je
suis ministre de l'économie et des
finances
et j'ai toujours considéré comme nombre
d'entre vous ici que la reconquête
industrielle était une ardente
obligation
dans un pays qui je le rappelle a
détruit les empoins industriels par
centaines de milliers qui a connu une
hémorragie industrielle comme aucun
autre grand pays industriel en Europe ni
l'Italie ni l'Allemagne n'ont connu
pareil hémorragien industrielle donc il
y a eu faux économique faute politique
faute collective sur l'industrie
nationale
mais c'est trop conquête ne peut pas se
faire ni en une année ni par un
claquement de doigts elle demande une
stratégie continue résolue déterminée
constante qui repose sur trois piliers
le premier c'est la baisse des charges
et l'allaègement de la fiscalité sur les
entreprises industrielles alors oui vous
avez raison nous ne sommes pas forcément
payés de retour Claude rénale mais ça
nous empêchera pas de tenir cette ligne
là parce que évidemment qu'une
entreprise industrielle j'étais il y a
quelques jours dans la vallée de larves
voir mes amis décolleteurs pour la
cinquième ou la sixième fois vous ne
pouvez pas demander à des industriels
qui sont confrontés à de telles défis de
partir avec le boulet d'un pot de
production 7 fois plus élevé que leurs
voisins allemands c'est tout simplement
impossible
vous ne pouviez pas leur demander de
faire la compétition alors qu'ils
avaient des cotisations patronales
beaucoup plus élevées que celles de leur
grands voisins européens donc nous avons
remédier à ces difficultés je rappelle
que c'est cette majorité qui a
transformé les allègements de charge qui
était un crédit d'impôt en allégement
définitif c'est cette majorité qui a
engagé la baisse d'un peu de production
c'est cette majorité qui a fait de la
France au territoire le plus attractif
pour les investissements étrangers c'est
le premier pilier de la reconquête
industrielle c'est pas le plus facile à
faire comprendre parce que à chaque fois
que nous baissons les impôts
sous-entreprises on nous dit cadeau pour
les entreprises non cadeau pour
l'industrie
cadeau pour les ouvriers
cadeaux pour la culture industrielle
nationale c'est différent
le deuxième pilier c'est évidemment la
formation la qualification qui passe par
une reconquête culturelle de l'industrie
française
ce n'est pas normal que dans un CFA que
j'ai visité là encore en Haute-Savoie
remarquable qui a 100% d'employabilité à
la sortie
trois offres d'emploi pour chaque gamin
qui travaille dans ce CFA il y a 400
places disponibles il y en a 300 qui
sont pourvu
ça n'est pas normal
c'est la preuve que il y a une
reconquête culturelle à faire sur
l'industrie française pour montrer à nos
enfants et en particulier aux jeunes
femmes parce que le taux de féminisation
est beaucoup trop faible que l'industrie
c'est plus là
que c'est la création c'est du
savoir-faire c'est la technologie c'est
des ingénieurs c'est de la valeur
ajoutée c'est des bons salaires c'est
des perspectives de carrière
enfin le troisième combat pour la
reconquête industrielle il passe par la
simplification de la vie des industriels
notamment pour l'installation de
nouveaux sites industriels je ferai des
propositions très concrètes à la
première ministre et au président de la
République dès le début de l'année 2023
sur ce sujet là mon objectif c'est que
la France
retrouve 15% de part de l'industrie dans
la richesse nationale d'ici 15 ans nous
sommes tombés à 10 ou 11%, il n'y avait
aucune raison pour cela je fixe comme
ambition 15% de part de l'industrie de
la richesse nationale d'ici 15 ans avec
les sites industriels les technologies
et les emplois qui vont avec
enfin sur le scénario de croissance ça
permet de faire la transition avec ce
que disait Jean-François Husson pardon
d'avoir été un peu long sur ce sujet qui
me tient à cœur bien entendu qu'il y a
d'autres scénarios
mais quand on présente un budget on
choisit un scénario central dans les
scénarios les plus sombres de la Banque
de France la Banque de France quand elle
élabore c'est scénarios par du principe
qu'il pourrait y avoir des coupures
d'énergie des délaissages sur les sites
industriels des arrêts de production
massifs à travers le territoire ça n'est
pas notre scénario central et ce que
nous avons fait avec Agnès panière une
hachée avec le plan d'économie d'énergie
le remplissage à 94% des stocks de gaz
la diversification des sources
d'approvisionnement c'est justement pour
ne pas être dans scénario donc je ne les
garde pas totalement d'un revers de la
main bien entendu ce serait très
audacieux de le faire je dis simplement
que notre scénario central reste une
croissance positive en 2023 à hauteur de
1%. que par ailleurs au-delà des mesures
que nous avons prises sur l'énergie nous
avons aussi eu à cœur de maintenir la
demande
des ménages français et que lorsque nous
soutenons les ménages lorsque nous les
protégeons contre l'inflation puisque
nous sommes un des seuls pays de la zone
euro où le pouvoir d'achat va continuer
à progresser en 2023 c'est aussi de
manière de soutenir notre croissance
enfin les réserves au départ reste
élevés dans notre pays je pense que
c'est aussi un motif de confiance sur
les collectivités locales je resterai
Gabriel répondre peut-être un mot sur la
transition écologique parce que je
partage totalement votre ambition je
voudrais simplement qu'on ne sous-estime
pas l'ampleur des transformations que
nous avons engagées avec le président de
la République et la première ministre
sur la transition écologique tout en
ayant parfaitement conscience qu'il faut
aller plus vite qu'il faut faire mieux
qu'il faut déployer encore plus
massivement nos dispositifs je crois que
nous sommes dans la bonne direction
d'abord nous avons engagé un plan de
sobriété qui sera présenté le 6 octobre
qui est absolument clé et je veux
vraiment bien faire comprendre que les
économies d'énergie que nous allons tous
devoir faire dans les semaines qui
viennent c'est pas pour passer l'hiver
c'est pour passer le siècle
c'est pour nous permettre d'avoir dans
les décennies qui viennent une situation
climatique plus favorable
ne pensons pas que les économies
d'énergie c'est uniquement pour faire
face un problème conjoncturel le
problème est évidemment structurel et
c'est des changements de comportement
complet auquel nous devons être conduits
nous les citoyens les entreprises les
administrations pour réussir à lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique le
fond vert des collectivités locales non
c'est pas Isabelle c'est 1,5 milliards
d'euros dont nous pouvons discuter le
déploiement avec vous pour nous assurer
qu'il sera le plus efficace possible
l'accompagnement des ménages sur les
véhicules électriques sur ma prime rénov
c'est aussi des aides budgétaires
massives et je suis prêt une fois encore
c'est un des produits de dialogue de
Bercy qui était très utile à regarder
comment est-ce qu'on passe de rénovation
par geste à des rénovations plus
globales qui ont le sait sont mille fois
plus efficaces pour lutter contre le
richement climatique et
éviter les pertes thermiques enfin deux
éléments complémentaires je rappelle que
France 2030 consacre la majorité de ces
investissements à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et les
investissements verts et je veux redire
aussi que la stratégie énergétique
présentée par le Président de la
République à Belfort sobriété
accélération sous énergies renouvelables
et réalisation de six nouveaux EPR est
une manière aussi de garantir la
réduction de notre empreinte carbone
merci Gabriel Attal
oui très rapidement d'abord pour
répondre à Jean-François Husson sur la
question sur la présentation budgétaire
effectivement nous avons une nouvelle
présentation avec un périmètre des
dépenses de l'État qu'on appelle PDE
maintenant qui remplace les deux
définitions qu'on avait avant c'est à
dire la norme pilotable la norme de
dépenses pilotable et l'objectif total
de dépenses de l'État c'est pour plus de
lisibilité c'est pour avoir un périmètre
plus large aussi pour éviter et pour pas
laisser échapper au suivi et au pilotage
des larges pans de la dépense publique y
compris les prélèvements pour l'Europe
et les prélèvements sur recettes en
direction des collectivités locales
c'est le le la maîtrise des dépenses de
la progression des dépenses publiques
demandées aux collectivités locales
n'est pas liée à ce nouveau périmètre
dépense de l'État mais il y est à nos
engagements d'une maîtrise globale de la
progression des dépenses pour tenir nos
objectifs le déficit public donc
vraiment les deux ça fait deux sujets
différents sur la CV
précisément ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
a une concertation nourrie avec les
associations d'élus pour définir la
manière dont on penserait la CVAE on a
eu des heures entières de réunion avec
Christophe Béchu Caroline cailleux et
les associations d'élus ces dernières
semaines on les a toutes vues au moins
deux fois et la copie qui est présentée
dans les textes financiers n'est pas
celle qui était la nôtre au départ avant
ces échanges donc précisément pour
répondre à ce que vous disiez sur vous
décidez puis vous concerter non on a
concerté pour décider il y a eu un
certain nombre de bougies j'en note un
majeur qui est le passage d'un
prélèvement sur recettes à une fraction
de TVA c'est vrai qu'au départ on
voulait compenser la CVAE la suppression
de la CVE par un prélèvement sur
recettes auquel on appliquait une
dynamique de 2,5% par an qu'il a
dynamique moyenne de ces VAE des 8
dernières années ça nous semblait être
un gage de visibilité j'ai été pas très
favorable à une fraction de TVA pour une
autre raison d'abord parce que du coup
il y a moins de visibilité puisque la
TVA ces recettes évoluent
de manière moins prévisible qu’a
prélèvement sur recette l'autre raison
c'est que
somme désormais en majorité relative au
capital de la TVA je parle d'ici ici de
l'État puisque avec cette compensation
les recettes de lait de TVA affectées à
l'état ce sont désormais en dessous de
50% des recettes de TVA et l'essentiel
des recettes de TVA seront désormais
affectées aux organismes de sécurité
sociale ou collectivités locales ça
change pas grand chose sur le fond si ce
n'est que pour l'avenir pour des
majorités qui auraient apprendre des
décisions sur la TVA je pense qu'il
pourrait y avoir du débat à ce moment-là
avec les principaux bénéficiaires entre
guillemets des recettes de TVA qui
diront vous prenez une décision mais on
est aussi principalement concernés mais
on a bougé sur ce sur ce point là et
donc on a donné la fraction de TVA
conformément à ce que demandait les
associations d'élus ensuite la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
territorialiser la dynamique de
compensation de la CVAE en gros comment
est-ce qu'on permet aux maires au patron
de PCI de pouvoir continuer à dire à ses
administrer on accueille une activité
économique sur le territoire c'est aussi
intéressant pour les une recette de la
collectivité et c'est là où on a
commencé la discussion avec les
associations d'élus avec vous dans le
cadre des dialogues de Bercy ce qu'on a
retenu pour l'instant et dans le texte
c'est de prendre comme critère les bases
de CFE qui sont déjà aujourd'hui un des
critères de territorialisation des
recettes de CVAE plusieurs associations
d'élus et parlementaires nous ont dit
les bases de CFE c'est pas suffisant il
faudrait enrichir les critères on a dit
qu'on était ouvert à des propositions
pour l'instant on en a pas reçu mais
dans les débats parlementaires je suis
sûr qu'il y aura des propositions sur ce
sujet là on est très ouvert donc pour
répondre à votre question sur la
gouvernance du fond etc moi mon objectif
c'est que la gouvernance du fond est le
moins de décision possible à prendre dès
lors qu'on aurait des critères
suffisamment
efficaces pour mesurer l'attractivité
économique des territoires l'affectation
des recettes de CV se fera à partir de
ces critères là
et dernier point pardon sur les
dialogues de Bercy très ouvert à ce
qu'on revoit le périmètre c'est vrai
qu'on a retenu le bureau des groupes des
commissions finances assemblées et Sénat
plus un représentant par groupe en
considérant que représentant du groupe
communiquerait les informations assez
collègues de son groupe et qu’un format
plus resserré permettait de fluidifier
les changes enfin si enfin moi c'est
plutôt un bon signe si on me dit qu'il y
a plus de monde qui va y participer pour
les prochaines éditions et je suis tout
à fait prêt à ce qu'on revoit le
périmètre
merci monsieur le ministre nous
démarrons donc les questions je vous
rappelle que nous donnons d'abord la
parole à une un sénateur par groupe sauf
sur le groupe LR contenu de son
importance nous nous accepterons de voir
Christine lavard des Roger carotc dans
un premier temps merci monsieur le
Président juste pour pour commencer
j'avais oui j'avais pas forcément prévu
d'en parler mais quand j'entends le
ministre le maire j'ai eu l'impression
que les critiques s'adressaient
notamment au groupe les républicains de
se dire vous ne demandez moins de
dépenses publiques mais plus de soutien
aux entreprises je voudrais juste
rappeler que le gouvernement se félicite
des recettes fiscales meilleures que
prévu notamment du fait des rentrées qui
viennent des entreprises donc c'est
pourquoi que nous pensons qu'il est
utile de les soutenir je ferme cette
première cette parenthèse et juste pour
essayer peut-être de commencer à poser
quelques questions pour essayer de mieux
comprendre alors notamment vraiment le
ministre Attal nous a parlé de la DGF et
j'ai compris que donc la version qu'on a
est déjà obsolète puisqu'il
conviendrajouter des crédits
supplémentaires donc peut-être qu'il
faudrait nous expliquer le mécanisme
parce que effectivement le texte prévoit
bien une augmentation de DSU et de DSR
financé sur l'enveloppe normée donc
c'est il faut comprendre qu'il y a 200
trente millions qui viennent enfin 210
qui viennent en plus des crédits déjà
inscrits donc ça c'était la première
question la seconde question concerne
toujours un sujet qui a été
effectivement alors vous dites vous nous
avez entendu dans les dialogues de Bercy
mais peut-être pas assez vite pour que
ça figure dans le texte à savoir la
suppression de la référence des de la
réforme des valeurs locatives
professionnelles donc la question qu'on
a envie de vous poser est-ce juste un
report où allez-vous vraiment revoir
dans le fond la méthode utilisée parce
que le problème est plus tant la méthode
que le report en tant que tel d'un an si
c'est pour refaire la même chose à
l'automne prochain on se heurtera
exactement au même écueil et enfin
revenir sur un sujet qui ne figure pas
aujourd'hui dans le texte modulo une
petite augmentation des crédits mais
c'est le FCTVA en tout cas vous
trouverez le Sénat sur ce sujet que nous
n'avons absolument pas oublier
alors je voudrais aussi revenir c'est
toujours sur les collectivités locales
effectivement sur l'article 16 qui a été
évoqué par le rapporteur général et
celui qui vient encadrer la trajectoire
de dépenses des collectivités alors déjà
pour dire qu'en tant que tel il y a
quand même un grand flou vous
effectivement vous dites qu'il va y
avoir concertation avec les
collectivités vous leur demandez quand
même de présenter ces éléments dans leur
débat d'entation des présentations
budgétaires pour certaines collectivités
le débat de façon budgétaire c'est début
décembre voire plutôt pouvoir voter un
budget avant la fin de l'année donc je
sais pas comment elles vont faire
sachant que aujourd'hui l'article est
quand même assez flou si ce n'est dire
que on a une augmentation limitée à
3,8%, je vous rappelle juste qu'on a
déjà une augmentation de la masse
salariale de 3,5% qui pèse pour toutes
les collectivités pour plus de 50% des
dépenses et que si on prend juste les
dépenses d'inflation sur le volet
énergie alimentation papier qui sont
quand même des charges très important
pour les collectivités on est bien
au-delà de 3,8 donc en fait globalement
vous demandez aux collectivités de
diminuer drastiquement leurs dépenses
enfin voilà c'est ce que je sais ce que
on retient donc et alors aujourd'hui
c'est plus contrat de Cahors et autres
mais derrière qu'est-ce qui se décline
est-ce que vous prévoyez un régime de
sanctions pour les collectivités qui ne
respecteraient pas ce qui était prévu
dans les contrats de Cahors est-ce que
vous prévoyez des déclinaisons par
suivant les spécificités des
collectivités parce que toutes ne sont
pas exposés à de la même manière au choc
d'inflation que je viens de que je viens
de décrire enfin voilà j'entends
concertation avec les collectivités mais
quand et dans quel calendrier
et enfin vous êtes oui la dernière salle
c'est la salle veuve verte pour toujours
abonder aussi dans le sens des propos du
rapporteur général effectivement pour
nous aussi le compte n'y est pas jusqu'à
présent alors effectivement j'ai relevé
que l'article 14 de la programmation des
finances publiques prévoient un
rééquilibrage d'ici 2027 avec une
diminution des dépenses fiscales
défavorables par rapport aux dépenses
fiscales FA
je relève juste que les premières
réformes qui a voulu être faites dans
l'ancien quéquennat ont toujours été
reportées à des temps meilleurs donc
j'ai envie de vous croire le
différencier est tellement important ce
sera pas très difficile de faire mieux
et sur l'article 7 franchement
adaptation du système fiscal aux
exigences de la transition écologique ou
énergétique enfin il faut regarder le
détail parce que c'est enfin je vois pas
en quoi on répond aux différentes aux
différentes exigences juste par les
mesures qui nous sont proposées je pense
que dans les dialogues de Bercy on a
largement parlé du besoin de faire de la
vraie rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments et je n'ai absolument rien
trouvé sur ce thème là dans l'ensemble
des documents qui nous ont été proposés
merci Christine Roger de rester une
minute
non non non 30 secondes mais c'est moi
je vais être beaucoup plus bref mais je
voudrais revenir vraiment à ce que vous
retenez comme taux de croissance je
rappelle que ici même en 2020 en 2021
vous m'avez dit lorsque je vous disais
c'est impossible vous ne parviendrez pas
vous me répondiez Cassandre ça n'est pas
possible bien sûr qu'on va les atteindre
et on est très très loin des taux que
vous aviez indiqué en 2020 en 2021 pour
les années suivantes alors bien sûr il y
a eu la crise de la covid bien sûr il y
a eu la guerre en Ukraine bien sûr il y
a la crise de l'énergie bien sûr il y a
l'inflation mais est-ce que tout ça
disparaît en 2023
qui vous a dit que la guerre en Ukraine
allait s'arrêter qui vous dit que la
crise énergétique qui n'est pas que sur
le niveau des prix mais aussi sur la
réorientation le la nouvelle politique
des pays producteurs qui vous dit que
tout cela ne va pas s'accroître
s'approfondir et être finalement
extrêmement difficile à gérer et que
l'inflation ne baissera dans ces
conditions certainement pas en 2023 donc
quand vous dites nous retenons un
chiffre moyen
1% c'est le chiffre moyen par rapport à
quoi parce que tous les autres banques
de France dit 0,5 au CDE dit 06 et
encore l'OCDE dit 06 mais en fait comme
nous pensons que l'Allemagne rentrera
probablement des pressions en 2023 ça
aura des conséquences pour la France qui
pourrait être ramené à zéro je n'ai vu
aucun organisme dire deux
ce qui aurait permis de dire entre le
zéro ou le 05 des uns et le 2 des autres
on a pris un mais là vous avez pris une
vision très optimiste alors Monsieur
Attal nous dit que il y a pas de boule
de cristal il y a une boussole mais
est-ce que c'est pas une boussole quand
même un petit peu
désorienté parce que on a l'impression
que sous prétexte de politique
volontariste vous êtes franchement dans
un optimisme qui m'inquiète parce que
vous annoncez vous même que la France va
emprunter 270 milliards d'euros ou
dites-vous même que les déficits ont
obamo de 5% 2023 probablement de 6%,
vous créez des posts que je ne conteste
pas sur la sécurité etc mais vous créez
6000 places d'hébergement vous créez
beaucoup de choses et je conteste pas
une politique volontariste mais on voit
pas en parallèle de réduction de
dépenses le parvenir là-dessus mais de
fait beaucoup de dépenses volontaristes
dans un environnement extrêmement
difficile alors que
le président de la République nous avait
annoncé lui-même un budget de guerre un
budget de crise et on a l'impression
d'avoir un budget classique très
optimiste et probablement inatteignable
merci Roger carotschi Jean-Marie maison
puis Éric Bocquet
j'aurais évoqué un sujet qui ne relève
pas la stratégie globale du PLF pour
2023 mais qui a été évoqué par le
ministre tout à l'heure Monsieur le
Maire
ce que voulez-vous moi je n'ai pas été
au dialogue de Bercy je ne vais pas j'ai
déjà du mal à aller là où je suis habité
pour ne pas aller là où je ne suis pas
invité donc
ce sujet ça concerne la fourniture et le
marché de l'électricité qui fait
l'actualité depuis un certain nombre de
semaines et comme d'autres ici j'imagine
j'ai rencontré un certain nombre de
chefs d'entreprises qui ont fait
ressentir
l'angoisse qui est la leur je parle
d'entreprise qui voit leur prix proposer
multiplié par plus de 10
elles ne savent pas comment faire les
sont très inquiète alors moi je voulais
vous poser la question plusieurs
questions qui relèvent de
leur manière de voir et une proposition
qui pourrait être la solution attendue
par elle vous avez évoqué monsieur
Mister mais je ne pense pas que
cette solution soit celle qui est a été
présenté par vous-même rapidement tout à
l'heure je voulais vous demander est-ce
que vous êtes favorable pour mettre en
place de nouvelles règles dans le sens
attendu par les fournisseurs et les
clients pour l'approvisionnement en 2023
je pense aux particuliers aux règles de
fonctionnement de la RNH de l'ARENH
ainsi qu'à l'organisation du marché de
l'électricité je sais
que celle-ci dépendent énormément du
niveau européen
que la valeur que le volume d'arenage a
été porté à 120 terawatts
et que le prix de l'arnh peut être ne
peut être désormais à faire à 49,50 € en
application de la loi sur le protection
du pouvoir d'achat du mois d'août
dernier néanmoins
seriez-vous favorable monsieur le
ministre a une nouvelle augmentation du
plafond du volume de l'arenage qui de
120 et qui pourrait
ça fait plaisir à EDF
deuxième question c'est concrète
envisagez-vous de permettre à tous les
clients de bénéficier d'offres grâce à
une garantie de l'État à portée au
fournisseurs de ses clients comme un peu
parce que voyez-vous il y a des
fournisseurs
qui ne trouvent pas d'offres et parfois
parce que ces offres n'existent pas le
marché est totalement insécurisé il y a
des offres qui se font le matin à 11
heures qui prennent fin à midi et en se
réserve le droit de l'annuler avant si
les marchés fluctue donc il faudrait me
demander-t-il qu'il y ait un espèce de
fournisseur de dernière recours qui
pourrait être
l'État pour permettre à ces entreprises
de trouver une solution à leurs
problèmes et enfin cette question
concerne plutôt monsieur Attal parce
qu'il a évoqué tout à l'heure
la commission de révision des locaux
professionnels de valeur locative des
locaux professionnels je suis dans un
département où la Commission n'a pas
fini ses travaux est-ce qu'elle doit
donc arrêter
merci merci
Jean-Marie Rick Bocquet puis Vanina
Paoli
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
évoquer deux points d'abord celui de la
CVAE et un point cher au cœur de
Monsieur le Maire les supers profits moi
je rêve d'une République où on
demanderait la vie des maires quand on
décide de supprimer des impôts
taxe professionnelle en son temps taxe
d'habitation CV aujourd'hui nous sommes
nombreux je pense ces temps-ci à
participer à des assemblées générales
des congrès de d'associations d'élus
dans les départements j'étais au maire
ruraux la semaine dernière dans le Nord
je serai au maire du Nord à Douai ce
vendredi et ce qui vient très fortement
en ce moment c'est l'inquiétude parfois
la panique par rapport à la hausse les
prix de l'énergie les mers se demandent
comment ils vont honorer leur facture
certains se demandent ils vont pas avoir
un budget en déséquilibre il y a
vraiment quelque chose d'important et de
grave qui se passe d'ailleurs les mers
ruraux adopté une motion à l'unanimité
c'est pas trop dans leurs habitudes mais
pour demander que la mise en place d'un
bouclier ce tarifaire sur l'énergie un
seul exemple une commune de mon
département de la métropole lilloise
27000 habitants mais on l'a tous des
exemples de ce style budget primitif
900000 euros de dépenses prévues
dépenses effectives 2 millions 4 sur un
fonctionnement de 34 millions sur une
seule année donc ça veut dire que cette
commune honorera ses factures d'ici la
fin d'année mais l'excédent disponible
en prochain sera en net diminution alors
pensez-vous vraiment qu'il est
responsable et sérieux de supprimer la
CVAE parce qu'on n'a pas demandé la vie
des élus là-dessus
dans un moment où les collectivités vont
se trouver dans des difficultés accrues
par rapport à cette raison là et
beaucoup d'autres historiques ancienne
sur leur autonomie financière la CVAE
c'était aussi un impôt très dynamique et
vous cassez ça au service des
collectivités franchement alors je sais
que vous avez réitéré cet engagement
face aux Medef fin août je pense qu'il y
a une préoccupation forte qui monte chez
les élus vous en entendrez sans doute
parler au Congrès des maires en novembre
prochain donc est-ce le bon moment c'est
pas un problème de différer sur deux
trois quatre ans est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée de de priver les de cette
ressources les collectivités la deuxième
question c'est sur la taxation des super
profils vous pensiez sans doute que les
débats seraient clos après le débat du
pdf.r fin juillet début août ici le vote
du Parlement qu'il avait pas adopté
cette disposition malgré des amendements
parvenus de différents groupes de cette
assemblée vous pensiez que le débat
était que or il resurgit avec force dans
cette rentrée pour les raisons que je
viens indiquer
et vous dites ne pas savoir ce que sont
des super trophies une proposition
simple prenons les trois années
antérieures à l'année covid prenait 17
18 19 vous faites une moyenne des
profits réalisés par les groupes du CAC
40 par exemple à cette époque là et on
aura une petite idée de ce que peut être
la notion de super profit à partir de là
donc on reviendra dans le débat bien sûr
avec d'autres je pense sur ce sujet mais
je pense que le débat n'est pas clos je
ne vois rien dans ce PLF de cette nature
merci
Eric Vanina pour les jeun puis Rémy
Ferro oui monsieur le Président merci en
premier lieu au nom des indépendants du
Sénat je souhaitais saluer la dynamique
de consultation qui a été engagée via
les dialogues de Bercy en amont de la
discussion du projet de loi de finance
je ne vais pas entrer dans des
considérations macroéconomiques j'aurais
deux ordres de questions
la première elle concerne les forêts
donc effectivement ce que vous avez
précisé monsieur le ministre de l'action
et des comptes publics et
louable je voulais savoir si vous êtes
ouvert à d'autres dispositifs on va
discuter prochainement ici d'une
proposition de loi que je porte sur les
la valorisation des externalités
positives de la forêt et on souhaitait
éventuellement mettre en place un
dispositif fiscal à l'endroit des
particuliers des entreprises qui
souhaitaient financer via le mécénat les
communes forestières qui pour beaucoup
d'entre elles sont en difficulté est-ce
que les dispositifs que vous décrivez
pourront être enrichi ou le gouvernement
n'est-il pas ouvert à
des aménagements ensuite je souhaitais
évoquer le crédit d'impôt recherche avec
vous j'ai entendu qu'il y avait des
collègues à l'Assemblée nationale qui
planchaient sur une éventuelle réforme
et je à ma connaissance je n'ai rien vu
dans le budget
là encore nous avons conduit ici une
mission d'information sur l'excellence
de la recherche et la pénurie de
champion industriels en France
nous souhaiterions un enveloppe
constante qui est une réallocation
d'une partie des crédits du crédit
d'impôt recherche fléchés vers les PME
après le quoi qu'il en coûte le combien
ça coûte l'heure du mieux qu'il en coûte
est arrivé et l'effet de levier du
crédit d'impôt recherche sur les
dépenses des PME et trois fois supérieur
à celui des dépenses des grands groupes
donc voilà c'est une proposition qu'on
vous refera deux petites questions
relatives aux collectivités
territoriales je voulais évoquer le SPIC
vous savez ce fond qui devait être
transitoire un peu comme la Cadès dans
un autre registre qui existe toujours et
qui ne fait pas que des heureux dans la
ruralité toujours donc je voulais savoir
si les modifications que vous prévoyez
l'article 45
notamment sur le des terres d'exclusion
de reversement du pic vont affecter la
clé de répartition ou non
et enfin sur la taxe d'aménagement même
question sur les modalités d'attribution
qui ont été modifiées récemment il a été
rendu obligatoire le reversement de la
taxe perçue par la commune aux EPCI
c'est une obligation qui a été mal
perçue par un certain nombre de maires
notamment dans les zones rurales ça a
modifié un certain nombre d'équilibre
économique je voulais savoir si vous
aviez prévu de revenir sur cette
décision ou si vous aviez des retours
d'expérience en fait sur ce nouveau
régime
de taxes d'aménagement merci merci
Vanina Rémy frérot puis Daniel Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président je reviens
pas sur la question sur les super
profits Eric Bocquet l'a posé mais c'est
en effet une question absolument au
centre du débat politique donc c'est
important qu'on vous interroge aussi sur
cette question messieurs les ministres
d'autant que Monsieur le Ministre
Lemaire ça ne rentre pas dans les impôts
de production
et la proposition qui est faite
aujourd'hui est une proposition
temporaire et non pas une proposition
d'une taxation pérenne donc je pense que
même si nous ne partageons pas la
politique la philosophie politique du
gouvernement
c'est une proposition d'équilibre à un
moment très particulier de l'histoire
qui ne remet pas en cause l'ensemble de
votre politique moi j'avais deux
questions l'une sur comment s'inscrit
l'éventuelle réforme des retraites dans
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques parce que bien compris que
que cette réformée lieu ou pas dans le
courant de l'année 2023 vous considérez
sûrement juste titre qu'elle n'a pas
d'impact sur la réalisation budgétaire
en 2023 mais ça en a forcément sur la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques d'ailleurs vous le dites dans
votre introduction mais dans le texte
lui-même la phrase est à la fois très
courte et très civiline la la
possibilité de notre trajectoire
reposera notamment sur les réformes
structurelles engagées je sais pas
d'ailleurs si la réforme des retraites
rentre dans les réformes structurelles
engagées ou non ça demande quand même un
peu plus de
précisions de détails et certainement
de chiffres ensuite sur la question des
collectivités locales
on a parlé de la CVAE de la CFE de la
difficulté aussi à trouver des
dispositifs pour compenser la perte de
ces recettes pour les collectivités
locales et aussi des besoins de tenir
compte des dynamiques territoriales
est-ce que vous êtes prêts même si ça
n'est pas dans le budget actuellement
mais à regarder aussi comment retrouver
ses dynamiques sur d'autres sujets alors
il y a les questions qui tiennent qui
peuvent par ailleurs abonder l'objectif
de politique du logement taxe sur les
logements vacants taxes sur les
résidences secondaires même si une taxe
sur les logements vacances c'est l'État
qui la perçoit mais de revoir ce
dispositif et deuxièmement est-ce que ça
compte beaucoup du coup pour beaucoup de
communes notamment celle où je suis élu
à Paris à revoir les limitations qui
sont aujourd'hui imposées à la taxe de
séjour et qui n'est pas un impôt qui
repose sur
les contribuables français
particulièrement mais justement sur le
tourisme qui est aussi dans notre pays
beaucoup du tourisme international
ce qui évitera certainement d'ailleurs à
beaucoup de collectivités locales de
devoir augmenter la taxe foncière ce que
vous êtes prêt à redonner des marges de
manoeuvre sur différents modes
d'imposition aux collectivités locales
merci Rémi daniel broyier Merci
Président Monsieur des mini chers
collègues
en introduction de vos propos monsieur
le ministre vous avez évoqué les
incertitudes très fortes qui pèse au
plan énergétique au plan de l'inflation
je veux rajouter même si vous y êtes
venu à la fin de votre propos
l'accélération gravissime de la crise
climatique que nous traversons l'été la
illustré pour tous ceux qui pourraient
encore en douter à travers les
sécheresses les incendies ou les
événements majeurs mais ça n'est pas un
problème national c'est un problème
international le Pakistan montre les
enjeux géostratégiques que cette crise
climatique fait peser sur le devenir sur
les migrations sur la vivabilité même
des villes et des territoires c'est la
raison pour laquelle ma première
remarque sera pour vous dire que les
propositions que vous nous faites même
si les mots annoncent des inflexions
très loin du compte et puisque on est
dans les combien ça coûte moi je
voudrais vous dire combien ça coûtera de
ne pas nous mettre à la bonne hauteur je
vais illustrer par quelques chiffres
premier chiffre en gros il va y avoir il
y a eu 40 milliards il va y avoir 36
milliards ou 16 milliards net de
boucliers énergétiques il va y avoir
deux milliards et demi sur l'isolation
des bâtiments mais si on veut quitter
notre dépendance au gaz russe et ne pas
tomber dans la dépendance au gaz de
schiste il faut mettre un facteur 10 sur
cette engagement il faut plutôt mettre à
minima 10 milliards sur l'isolation
thermique il faut mettre aussi des
crédits sur la place du rail on n'est
pas du tout dans les ordres de grandeur
qui permettent de bouleverser il y a
tout un autre volet qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas toujours un volet coûteux sur la
sobriété qui est annoncée mais qui
mérite pas des mesures mais vraiment un
engagement
collectif pour une sobriété heureuse
donc il y a sur ces sujets la nécessité
de dégager des moyens d'action alors
supprimer la CV VAE
de notre point de vue ça n'est vraiment
pas le moment c'est un désarmement de la
capacité de l'État à agir dans ce
domaine comme dans le domaine de la
justice sociale donc nous nous sommes en
désaccord mais si vous maintenez cette
volonté que vous avez réaffirmé
rencontre après rencontre à minima
messieurs les ministres proposés des
conditionnalités climatiques ou sociales
ou ceux des salaires en ce qui lorsqu'il
s'agit d'entreprises qui vont bénéficier
d'une réduction des impôts ou
engagements climatique chiffrés pour ces
mêmes entreprises et pareillement pour
l'État toutes les mesures que nous
prenons devraient être mesurées à l'aune
de leur impact sur la crise climatique
ou sur la justice sociale il y a comme
ça des niches fiscales qui méritent
d'être regardées je l'ai révoquerai pas
ici en vous fera des propositions
il y a notre proposition évidemment je
redis ce qu'on dit mes collègues sur la
question de la taxation sur les super
profits avec un petit regret monsieur
adminis le maire que vous n'ayez pas lu
ou apprécié à sa juste valeur ce qui a
été déposé par les groupes de gauche et
écologiste qui définit très correctement
ce qu'est cette taxation et qui n'en
fait pas une taxation pérenne comme ça
vient d'être dit par mon voisin mais
nous proposons aussi un ISF climatique
parce qu'il faut aider les gens les plus
aisés ceux qui dépensent le plus et
émettent le plus d'émissions de CO2 à
réduire ses émissions et l'ISF peut
avoir un impact très positif si les
conditionné à des enjeux climatiques
dernier point sur les collectivités
territoriales le fond vert d'un milliard
et demi n'est clairement pas la hauteur
non plus or les collectivités
territoriales seront sans nul doute
c'est notre conviction le premier
facteur de la transition écologique du
pays et dans une République
décentralisée je crois que nous devrions
prendre au moins autant soin des
collectivités territoriales que vous le
faites des entreprises et soutenir leur
capacité à agir tant dans la cohésion
sociale que dans cette transition
écologique voilà sur tous ces facteurs
nous vous ferons des propositions et je
termine quand même sur une question les
collectivités ce qui a dit mon collègue
boke la commune dont j'étais mère à 2
millions d'augmentation de ces frais
d'énergie j'ai visité avec le président
du SEDAL du Sénat l'Institut Gustave
Roussy ou à la quelques jours 5 millions
de hausses des frais d'énergie pour un
hôpital mais où aller chercher cette
augmentation du coût de l'énergie
lorsqu'on est un hôpital il y a là un
sujet je rajoute les universités qui ont
par ailleurs souvent des locaux
un bouclier tarifaire pour les
collectivités sur l'énergie pour les
collectivités les hôpitaux les
universités merci Daniel
donner la parole à Jean-Claude requier
puis à Pascal Savoldelli oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
que vous n'étiez pas récompensé des
efforts fournis en faveur certaines
catégories sociales le président a dit
que pas payé de retour
je suis pas sûr que de faire des efforts
pour l'éducation vous ayez le mode des
enseignants c'est comme pour faire des
efforts pour l'écologie que vous allez
voir des écologistes mais ça c'est un
autre débat on n'est pas là pour gagner
les catégories sociales mais on est là
pour essayer de gérer un pays et de
résoudre l'ancien problème alors ce
budget n'ont pas encore étudié ta chaîne
dans le groupe mais il y a beaucoup de
dépenses c'est vrai
assez peu de d'économies mais je
comprends que la situation est difficile
et qu'il faisait soutenir
l'économie qui est en difficulté alors
quelques interrogations simplement
certaines ont été posées en particulier
sur le crédit impôt recherche ça a été
fait donc un petit mot sur le prix de
relance qui vont se terminent en 2023
quelle est la proportion des crédits
engagés consommés actuel et a-t-on une
évaluation de leur efficacité de la
question c'est pour l'Ukraine on a voté
les crédits en pdfr pour l'Ukraine on va
invoquer sûrement PLF et à ton idée de
l'évaluation de du montant trois
questions la ciao la suppression d'un
CVAE il y aura-t-il une compensation
pour les départements et est-ce que ce
sera proposé comme ça a été fait pour le
RSA pour les départements en paix puis
enfin je dirais que ce PLF est
relativement court puis je crois que
mais est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre dans des modifications au
cours de l'examen parlementaire nous
nous verrons
merci Jean-Claude alors parce que ça
vole des lits puis Bernard delcro
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres avant de porter une
impression sur seulement deux sujets
on est dans une situation inédite
puisque on a une forte hypothèse de 49-3
l'Assemblée nationale non parce que
pouvoir aussi impression de parler dans
une bulle mais les dialogues se font
quand même avec une épée de Damoclès
et quand on a les lits de l'opposition
et ne croyez pas en moi de faire la
victime mais 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale et un budget de droite annoncé
ça fait droite + droite + droite donc
les offres de dialogue à l'opposition il
faut après les démontrer donc il faut
nous dire et moi aujourd'hui comme la
première fois où j'ai été au dialogue de
Bercy et je ne suis pas retourné je ne
vois aucune proposition faite aux
oppositions parlementaires concrètes
donc faut un langage de vérité et dans
le langage de vérité je vous avoue une
seule satisfaction et là je vous accorde
sur le maire franchement c'est honnête
c'était bien de nous dire dès le départ
qui avait pas 45 milliards pour le
bouclier tarifaire
il était temps
et vous avez eu l'honnêteté de nous dire
que c'est seulement 16 milliards donc
c'est dit c'est fait dont acte et ça
s'apprécie mais après il y a un sujet là
je vous avoue tout à l'heure j'ai
attendu mon tour avec beaucoup
d'apaisement mais quand je vous vois
parler de la même manière des
entreprises que des collectivités
territoriales en prenant les mêmes
critères des 2 millions de chiffre
d'affaires ou de moins de 10 salariés là
je me dis que c'est un virage politique
que vous prenez c'est la première fois
et s'il est plus anciens diront si je me
trompe si eux utilisent la même
critérisation pour les collectivités
territoriales que pour les entreprises
c'est la première fois que j'entends ça
avec toutes les conséquences que ça va
avoir pour les collectivités
territoriales alors on peut me dire
l'Europe tout ça je vois bien les
négociations et je vous encourage à
gagner mais il y a un moment si on peut
le faire pour ces collectivités
territoriales il faut le faire pour les
autres vous nous annoncez 420 millions
d'euros les a déjà votés c'est des plats
réchauffés on les a votés même nous
l'opposition les a voté
donc c'est un plat réchauffé donc il y a
rien de neuf de ce côté-là donc moi je
vous poserai question est-ce que vous
allez avoir la volonté politique de
revenir à la tarification réglementée de
la vente de l'énergie
pour les collectivités territoriales et
des entreprises demandeuses voilà une
bonne fois pour toutes et alors
évidemment venir mais comment et bah il
faut indexer au prix de production des
indexées du prix du marché de la
spéculation voilà ça c'est une
proposition alors elle est peut-être
d'opposition mais au moins c'est une
proposition responsable la deuxième
chose et jean-philis parce que ça a pas
été traité par le président rénal
celle-là était et personne lui a répondu
la question de la tranche des revenus
il a raison moi je vous fais tout de
suite une économie au moins de 3
milliards vous allez faire un cadeau
fiscal à 905000 foyers qui touchent plus
de 100.000 euros de revenus fiscal par
tranche
vous moi si vous me demandez et c'est là
que l'opposition elle peut être entre
guillemets constructive si vous me dites
que les premières tranches il fallait
revariser je vous dis oui et vous avez
raison et dans ces cas là je vote pour
donc c'est pas de l'obstination mais
expliquez-moi en quoi les 905000 foyers
qui ont des revenus
fiscaux de référence par tranche de plus
de 100000 il faut le raccorder la même
revalorisation enfin franchement je vous
le dis avec un peu de véhémence
[Musique]
se cachent des inégalités très très
fortes entre les collectivités et je
pense notamment pas seulement mais
notamment aux collectivité rurales
puisqu'il est admis aujourd'hui que
l'inflation est un point à deux points
supérieurs en milieu en milieu rural et
donc je pense qu'il faut répondre à
cette disparité et aux difficultés
rencontrées par un certain nombre de
collectivités alors ça a été fait pour
2022 à travers ce qui a été voté dans le
dans le PLFR et je me réjouis de
l'annonce qui a été fait d'une
augmentation de la DSR et de la DSU pour
210 millions d'euros
pas prise sur l'enveloppe normée mais
abondez pour pouvoir financer cette
péréquation au-delà de l'enveloppe
normée ça a été dit c'est une très bonne
mesure parce c'est aussi une façon de
répondre parce que quand on perçoit de
la DSR de la DSU moi c'est que on se
trouve par situation extrêmement
favorable mais au-delà au-delà de de
cette augmentation de la péréquation que
je salue
comment le gouvernement peut-il
envisager en 2023
d'accompagner plus particulièrement les
collectivités qui se trouvent les plus
fragilisées pour les questions
d'inflation et le temps de coût de
l'énergie sur 2022 ça a été réglé en
partie par le PFR mais comment pour 2023
peut-on faire ça vaut d'ailleurs pour
les collectivités rurales comme pour les
ménages dans des territoires où les
ménages sont contraints de prendre un
véhicule pour pouvoir se rendre au
travail ou dans les différents services
auxquels ils ont besoin d'accéder donc
voilà ma question porte sur
le gouvernement
envisage-t-il ou comment
pourrait-il dans tous les cas comment
envisage-t-il d'accompagner les
collectivités qui sont les plus touchées
et les ménages
je j'approuve le fond vert qui a été
évidemment à annoncé à 1,5 milliards
d'euros parce que je pense comme ça a
été dit par ailleurs que la réussite la
transition écologique et énergétique ça
passe aussi par par les territoires
peut-être pourriez-vous nous dire
comment le gouvernement envisage
qu'elle forme peut prendre cette cette
attribution collectivité c'est sous
forme d'appels à projet ou pas
j'ai aussi une question alors là vous
étonnera pas on a déjà eu l'occasion
d'en parler mais j'aimerais vraiment
avoir une réponse qui concerne les
dispositions fiscales qui sont adossés
aux politiques d'aménagement du
territoire on a déjà eu l'occasion d'en
parler dans les dialogues de Bercy que
je salue d'ailleurs puisque la mission
qui a été confiée à trois à trois
députés par le gouvernement propose la
suppression de ces dispositions fiscales
adossées un certain nombre de zonages
qui sont des politiques d'aménagement et
territoires je le répète et notamment
des RR évidemment je ne suis pas
comparable à ce lave ou vous en doutez
et d'autres et d'autres avec moi
Frédéric caspagnac avec laquelle j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur les questions de
ZRR également ou Rémi quintro donc
pouvez-vous nous dire qu'il n'en sera
rien nous assurer qu'il n'en sera rien
et que ces dispositifs pourronter pour
en être maintenu et puis dernier point
et après je m'arrête j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il était question de de baisser la
taxe sur les frais de chambre de métier
d'artisanat et je pense que chacun peut
contribuer d'ailleurs à l'effort de
redressement des finances publiques mais
pour les vœux de nous donner un peu de
visibilité sur la durée de manière plus
réelle cette fois-ci sur cette sur cette
question là merci Bernard Thierry cosi
et puis Sylvie vermillier j'annonce
qu'il y a ensuite trois autres
intervenants donc voilà je me suis dit
merci monsieur le Président je vais être
extrêmement bref puisque c'est mon
collègue delcro vient d'anticiper mon
intervention je voulais
je vais poser directement à la question
c'est est-ce que le gouvernement est
prêt à regarder de près une indexation
de la DGF sur l'inflation pour
accompagner les collectivités donc au
moins la réponse la question est très
directe la réponse aussi
voilà merci magnifique dans le même
esprit Sylvie Vernet merci monsieur le
président
[Musique]
qui n'a pas été abordé jusque là je fais
fort c'est l'évolution de la charge de
la dette
j'aimerais avoir votre
votre sentiment sur cette évolution qui
charge de la dette qui dépasserait 50
milliards en 2023
donc évidemment je me pose la question
des marges de manœuvre et
j'aborderai le chapitre des mises en
réserve de crédit j'ai lu que vous
prévoyez un gel de précaution de 8,1
milliards de crédits de paiement donc
peut-être que c'est une piste ce rabot
en quelque sorte générale mais je me
pose la question de cette déclinaisons
est-ce qu'elle doit être générale malgré
les hausses de budget sur sur certains
ministères l'intérieur la justice et
armées l'éducation nationale
nous nous sommes posés la question au
groupe Union centriste et c'est vrai que
c'est difficile de savoir de quelle
manière il faut trouver
des économies puisque c'est bien la
question mais je pense que la mise en
réserve elle est absolument nécessaire
pour faire face à des imprévus je pense
qu'on en aura des sérieux et comment
vous voyez c'est de façon un peu plus
claire c'est mis en réserve de crédit
sur la question du report de suppression
de la CVAE je pourrais pas m'empêcher de
dire que nous avions proposé nous le
report de la suppression de la
contribution audiovisuelle publique qui
représente tout de même 3 milliards 7 et
peut-être que là aussi c'était une piste
qui aurait pu être la bienvenue c'est
tout de même pas négligeable et puis
Monsieur le Maire je pense que la
suppression de la CVAE c'est une chose
mais je pense que le zéro
artificialisation nette fait beaucoup
plus de mal aux entreprises que les
bienfaits de la suppression de la CVAE
et puis pour terminer je remercie le
geste fait en direction des communes
forestières et le million supplémentaire
parce que certaines d'entre elles font
face à des difficultés ou ne font pas
face justement à des difficultés bien
réelles merci
merci
Sylvie Jean-Michel Arnaud puis Vincent
Seguin c'est le président monsieur le
ministre je reviens évidemment sur le
sujet qui est finalement le fil
directeur d'un Renault nous
interventions c'est évidemment la hausse
des prix de l'énergie on nous avait
rappelé dans quelles conditions
globalement serait plafonné
l'augmentation à hauteur de 15% à partir
de janvier 2023 pour la plupart des
particuliers je me permets d'insister
sur peut-être deux angles morts qui
apparaissent au vu des remontées de
terrain le premier c'est évidemment ça a
été évoqué très largement c'est la
question des collectivités locales qui
ne sont pas compensées hormis grâce à
l'action déterminant d'un certain nombre
de collègues lors de la discussion du
PLF
hormis un accompagnement qui est repris
dans le cas du PLF auteur de 450
millions d'euros il n'y a me semble-t-il
aucune avancée sur ce sujet et c'est une
alerte majeure dans tous les territoires
ma question est ce que nous devons nous
collectivités locales et conseiller à
nos collectivités locales de suivre le
conseil émis par le Président de la
République le 22 septembre dernier qui
est de dire ne signez pas aujourd'hui
vos contrats quand ils sont à des prix
fous ça s'adressait aux entreprises
est-ce que par élargissement nous devons
considérer que c'est également un
message adressé aux collectivités
locales j'attends avec beaucoup
d'attention votre réponse sur les angles
morts nous avons notamment pour les
dépenses des énergies gaz ou électricité
pour les copropriétés qui sont sous un
statut de personnes morales il
semblerait qu'effectivement elle ne
puisse pas bénéficier du tarif régulé ce
qui pose d'énormes difficultés et qui
risque de mettre en grande difficulté
les plus précaires que ce soit dans le
logement social ou simplement dans le
logement privé classique et puis dernier
sujet vous me permettrez en tant qu'élu
de la montagne d'aborder évidemment la
suite d'un certain nombre de
négociations de discussion en cas de
gros de travail encore mené cette
semaine pouvoir de quelle manière
pouvait être accompagner les stations de
tourisme en particulier les remontées
mécaniques quel que soit leur statut y
compris sous la forme de régie savoir si
nous allons aboutir à des propositions
puisque vous avez beaucoup concerté
j'aimerais que l'on puisse simplement
décider après le concertation puisque
nous avons une saison qui arrive et nous
devons avoir des réponses à un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui ont des
augmentations de 6 7 8 10 fois le coût
de leur contrat précédent et qui ne peut
pas réguler leur prix leur montée
mécanique alors que tout est déjà
commercialisé pour la saison à venir il
s'agit aussi d'attractivité la
compétitivité d'un secteur important du
tourisme dans ce pays qui est l'activité
divers je vous remercie merci
Jean-Michel Vincent Segoin puis Gérard
Longuet
oui merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous titré le
projet de loi de finance aller vers le
plein emploi ma première question c'est
à combien vous fixez l'objectif sachant
que nous sommes à 7,1 pour son chômage
aujourd'hui
et quel est l'objectif recherché non
deuxième point on voit pas de recette
supplémentaires dans le budget on va pas
de dépenses en moins au contraire on
apprend que le ministère du travail va
être pourvu de 6,2 milliards de budget
supplémentaires pour la formation et
pour les maisons France travail est-ce
la solution
avions-nous besoin de remettre des
budgets supplémentaires sachant que la
formation est déjà bien pourvue et le
fait de changer l'enseigne de Pôle
Emploi vers maison France travail est-ce
la solution pour régler nos problèmes de
plein emploi
merci Vincent Gérard Longuet puis
Sébastien Meurant et nous aurons nous
concurrons là oui merci monsieur le
Président oui je m'adresse à nos deux
ministres bon leur tâche n'est pas
facile il y a quand même une réflexion
qui m'étonne dans cette dans cette
présentation vous ne regroupez pas les
recettes et les dépenses prévisibles sur
moyens et long terme sur des secteurs
stratégiques dont les lignes de force
sont évidentes je prendrai trois
exemples la démographie
l'énergie et la défense je ne vais pas
évidemment développer mais sur la
démographie vous avez à la fois des
recettes en moins prévisibles car hélas
nous aurons moins d'élèves et donc moins
de besoin quantitatifs
sujets auxquels vous êtes attaqué tant
mieux vous avez mon collèguemoins
viennent d'évoquer le sujet de l'emploi
va s'analiser d'une façon différente
dans un pays où malheureusement la
démographie est en effet négative et où
là les perspectives de ressources en
main d'oeuvre diminue donc vous avez
nous aimerions qu'il y ait une
présentation sur les dépenses en moins
et des dépenses en plus car je n'imagine
pas que le Gouvernement n'envisage pas
une politique familiale pour soutenir la
démographie et reconstituer la vitalité
de la population française si je prends
l'exemple de l'énergie
le renouvelable est sans doute
indispensable enfin la vérité c'est que
sans le nucléaire nous ne réglerons pas
les besoins en énergie électrique qui
ont été depuis 10 ans délibérément et
scandaleusement sous-évalués et qui
aboutissent à la crise que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui or en
développant le nucléaire sur moyen et
long terme c'est en effet une affaire de
moyens à long terme il est bon de ne pas
changer tous les trois ans nous pouvons
espérer réduire les dépenses de CSPE qui
sont très lourdes aujourd'hui qui
représentent près d'un quart de la
facturation des ménages grâce à une
politique contenue enfin est soutenu du
nucléaire le dernier exemple c'est
évidemment la défense mais là il y a
trop d'inconnues pour ouvrir le débat
d'une façon sommaire vous faites des
efforts tant mieux mais nous aimerions
savoir quel est le projet de moyen et de
long terme dans un environnement où le
président de la République nous a dit à
la fois que l'OTAN était atteint touché
par une mort cérébrale il y a deux ans
de cela et que l'on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui qu'il y a un besoin de
défense européenne et donc sans doute
exemplaire entier pour exemple parité
une excellentarité française
ma question est très simple
imaginez-vous de regrouper sur des
grands axes stratégiques votre
présentation du budget avec les recettes
prévisibles en plus et les dépenses
prévisibles également
merci Gérard Sébastien Meurant c'est
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
lorsque l'on présente le budget qu'on
ambitionne une reconquête industrielle
évidemment on est tous d'accord
une des raisons principales de
l'inflation qui a été abordée c'est là
où de l'énergie et la France avait cette
chance historique liée aux
investissements massif fait par nos
aïeux de bénéficier d'un avantage
compétitif par rapport à nos concurrents
et notamment nos concurrents allemands
d'avoir une énergie peu chère du fait et
bien de mauvais choix qui ont été opérés
ces dernières années on aboutit à cette
folie qui est de produits de l'énergie
électrique pas cher du fait de la loi
Nome qui a été votée à une certaine
époque dans les conditions de marché
tout autre tout autre bien sûr Mika
était voté ou les prix de l'énergie bien
explosent et là on a au niveau
ménage au niveau entreprise des
collectivités les ménages qui sont
exclus qui sont qui sont qui vont être
pris qui sont prêts à la gorge ça a été
dit à plusieurs fois à plusieurs
reprises moi j'aimerais comprendre
comment ça va se passer pour des
intercommunalités qui voient leurs
factures de gaz multiplié par 6 elle des
collectivités qui sont gérés
correctement donc qui ont été prudentes
qui ont des marges de financement et le
risque c'est toujours qu'on aide ceux
qui sont les en plus en situation les
plus délicates parfois celles qui ont
moins bien géré de leur commune et
est-ce qu'on leur envisage au niveau
français de faire comme l'Espagne le
Portugal pour les prix d'énergie de
découpler par rapport au prix du gaz et
au prix donc ce qui se passe sur les
marchés européens et dans vos provisions
là je passe à la dette
la dette vous imaginez que les taux
d'intérêt ça n'a pas été beaucoup abordé
une collègue qui a posé la question mais
la charge d'intérêt va d'ici à 2025
assez peu augmenté donc là c'est une
provision effectivement très très
positive puisqu'on a bénéficié de des
taux d'intérêt négatifs en un certain
nombre d'années ce qui est une
aberration financière et là on revient à
une période plus normale là vous avez
imaginé que la dette va continuer à
augmenter mais que la charge de la dette
en 2025 sera sans possiblement
identique à celle de 2023 est-ce que ça
c'est pas faire également à Paris
extrêmement
positif sur l'avenir et concerné pour
terminer sur les sur la politique de
l'offre la politique de l'oeuf moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose sauf que
le résultat de cette politique de
l'offre depuis quelques années c'est le
déficit commercial et d'ici du
commercial c'est 156 milliards en
prévision en 2022 et 154 en 2023
donc certes il y a certainement
l'énergie dans ce dans ce chiffre bien
sûr tous c'est que la compétitivité de
la France vis-à-vis de nos concurrents
et notamment européens ne s'améliore
guère
merci monsieur le ministre il vous
reviennent de répondre à 90 questions à
peu près
c'est pour ça c'est le Président je vous
propose de ne pas répondre à chaque
sénatrice et sénateur de bourse je pense
très fastidieux et pas très intéressant
pour le débat il vaut mieux que on
regroupe les grandes questions qui ont
été posées surtout à cette heure avancé
d'abord peut-être un principe quand nous
avons étudié le PLF
à l'été je suis arrivé au débat et j'ai
indiqué que nous entrions avec 22
milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires et que nous devions
sortir avec 22 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires moi je fixe le
même principe pour le PLF nous entrons
avec 5% de déficit nous sortirons avec
5% de déficit public
et je veux redire à quel point la France
est à l'euro près
alors j'entends bien les remarques sur
les collectivités locales sur les
services publics sur d'autres personnes
qui souhaitent davantage protégées sur
un bouclier pour les entreprises mais
pardon tout cela n'est pas à la portée
de la France c'est aussi simple que cela
donc il faut faire des choix mais si on
me trouve des économies je dis pas des
taxes ou des impôts supplémentaires
parce que ça c'est la solution de
facilité à chaque fois j'y reviendrai
très bien mais quand on me dit il faut
indexer la DGS sur l'inflation où il
faut un bouclier tarifaire pour toutes
les entreprises je dis simplement que ce
n'est pas à la portée de notre bourse
et que nous devons te dire des 5% de
déficits publics
et que dans le fond il y a des
entreprises qui sont exposées la
concurrence internationale elles
arrivent plus à vendre évidemment quand
vous allez chez décollecteurs de la
vallée de l'art et qu'ils vendent des
pièces de véhicules automobiles et qui
doivent les vendre en Asie en leur dit
en Asie mais il y a pas de flamber les
prix il y a aucune raison qu'on paye
plus cher vos pièces cela il faut les
protéger
mais d'autres commerçants qui sont
restaurateurs par exemple
ils peuvent faire passer une partie de
la hausse dans leur prix de vente
donc je ne rétablirai pas des mesures de
quoi qu'il en coûte parce que ce serait
dispendieux pour les finances publiques
et que cela ne ferait qu'alimenter un
peu plus l'inflation dans les mois qui
viennent
et même chose pour les collectivités
locales bien sûr qu'il y a des communes
des comités de communes qui sont en
grande difficulté il faut les aider
puis il y en a d'autres qui sont moins
en difficulté puis il y en a d'autres
qui n'ont pas forcément fait de bons
choix de gestion au cours des deux ou
trois dernières années est-ce qu'il est
juste traité tout le monde la même
manière je suis pas certain
et je suis pas certain que nos
compatriotes approuveraient cela donc il
faut regarder de près et soutenir ceux
qui en ont besoin mais tenir cet
objectif 5% de déficit en 2023 et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez parfaitement
rappelé parce que vous connaissez les
sujets parfaitement en tenant les 5% de
déficit en 2023 nous ne sommes pas les
bons élèves de la zone euro
nous ne faisons que respecter la
trajectoire qui nous permettra de tenir
les 3% de déficit en 2027 ce qui fait je
le rappelle l'un des derniers États de
la zone euro à repasser sous les 3% de
déficit public
donc oui je serai un traitable sur ce
sujet parce qu'il envoie de la
crédibilité de la France la crédibilité
de nos finances publiques et qui n'a
aucune raison que la France accuse des
déficits plus importants que celle de
ces autres grands voisins européens
voilà pour le principe ensuite sur les
questions qui ont été posées sur la
croissance moi j'ai pas grand chose à
ajouter à ce que j'ai dit bien sûr que
l'environnement est particulièrement
instable et incertain ce que je constate
simplement portant de fait c'est que en
2021 la reprise a été plus forte que ce
que nous avions anticipé ce que je
constate c'est que parmi les grandes
économies de la zone euro Italie Espagne
Allemagne le premier pays à avoir
retrouvé son niveau d'activité
économique d'avancer c'est la France
parce que sa politique de relance a été
rapide efficace et puissante
ce que je constate aussi c'est que les
prévisionnistes disaient que nous ne
pourrions pas dépasser 2,3% de
croissance en 2022 relisez tout ce qui a
été dit
nous allons faire devient 7 et croyez
moi je suis tout aussi surpris par la
vigueur de la demande par la vigueur de
l'activité touristique le retour de
l'activité de service dans notre pays
qui est très puissante et tant mieux
donc le pire n'est pas certain il faut
certainement s'y préparer mais il n'est
pas certain et je crois que mon rôle de
ministre de l'Économie ça coûtait
parfaitement rappelé par le président
rénal c'est non pas de faire de la
prophétie auto-réalisatrice mais au
contraire de pousser le pays vers le
meilleur et vers ce qu'il peut accomplir
c'est-à-dire je pense 1% de croissance
en 2023
sur la CVL
bon je veux dire monsieur Laignel dont
j'ai lu les déclarations que je trouve
un peu révoltante par les cadeaux Medef
et je trouve pas que ce soit des propos
acceptables ni dignes
économie des finances ne prend pas des
mesures pour faire plaisir à qui que ce
soit
un organisation syndicale ou une
organisation patronale il le fait parce
qu'il estime que c'est bon pour le pays
nous ne prononcons cette décision parce
que nous estimons en conscience que nous
ne ferons pas de reconquête industrielle
avec des impôts de production cette fois
plus élevés que ceux de nos voisins et
que c'est maintenant que ça se joue
qu'il est urgence à le faire parce que
les marchés ils doivent être pris
maintenant que la reconquête
industrielle doit se faire maintenant et
que si nous n'avions pas baissé les
impôts de production de 10 milliards
d'euros je pense que jamais global fin
de Reese n'aurait investi chez ses
micros accroll à Grenoble et que la
France aujourd'hui ne serait pas une des
nations qui va pouvoir maîtriser les
technologies de semi-conducteur y
compris dans les gravures les plus fines
donc je n'accepte pas que qui que ce
soit aille parler de cadeau omedef quand
nous voulons d'abord nous battre pour la
reconquête industrielle on peut comme
vous le fait très bien ici discuter des
procédés échanger contester des
approches que nous prenons mais pas de
stigmatisation de cette sorte qui me
paraissent maladroite inappropriée et
injuste
sur le bouclier tarifaire pour répondre
aux questions qui m'ont été posées sur
ce sujet c'est un enjeu majeur c'est la
plus grande dépense publique de 2023
nouvelle dépense c'est 45 milliards
d'euros que nous mettons sur la table
c'est ce que ça va nous coûter
c'est ce que nous mettons pour protéger
nos compatriotes
y compris les entreprises
il va falloir compenser parce que quand
on dit ma séquence de hausse je rappelle
que le marché c'est 100%. donc si vous
voulez qu'on fournisse de l'électricité
qu'au fond du gaz il faut bien compenser
les producteurs qui perdent c'est comme
ça que ça se passe une réalité
économique et un marché et nous ne
sommes pas tout seuls au monde donc si
on veut avoir du gaz et en électricité
il faut le payer au prix du marché sinon
vous n'en avez pas c'est la pénurie et
c'est la chute économique ça coûte 45
milliards d'euros
peut-être plus si les chiffres
augmentent et si les prix augmentent
peut-être un peu moins si les prix
baissent à partir de là nous avons des
recettes 19 milliards d'euros qui
viennent des énergies renouvelables j'y
reviendrai c'est la question à la
taxation qui est une question tout à
fait digne politiquement importante ou
chacun a ses opinions à chacun ses
convictions elles sont toutes
respectables mais là nous récupérons 19
milliards d'euros de recettes des
énergies renouvelables sur les
énergéticiens à qui on a dit lorsque le
prix est bas on vous rembourse on fait
des investissements sur le renouvelable
sur l'éolien sur le soleil
donc ça vous coûte cher ça vous rapporte
pas beaucoup on vous compense on a
compensé pendant des années à hauteur de
milliards d'euros
quand le prix de l'énergie est
supérieure à ce prix garanti pas désolé
c'est nous qui récupérons l'argent
il s'agit je suis très favorable parce
que c'est une rente et qu'il n'y a
aucune raison qu'il y a des rende notre
pays ça a rapporté 8 milliards en 2022
ça rapportera 19 milliards d'euros en
2023 là dessus vous retranchez encore 9
milliards d'euros de TICE que nous ne
prélèverons pas cela vous amène à 17
milliards d'euros vous retirez un
milliard d'euros de recettes qui
viennent de l'énergie hydraulique il
n'était pas concerné jusqu'à présent
vous arrivez à 16 milliards d'euros de
coûts mais ce que dépense l'État en brut
ce qu'il met sur la table ce qu'il met
dans la poche des Français 45 milliards
d'euros
donc personne ne peut dire nous
protégeons pas massivement mais nous
réduisons la note grâce à ce système de
marché qui d'ailleurs a été adopté par
l'Union européenne
ensuite sur je regrette que Monsieur
Salbris soit parti ce que je voulais lui
répondre sur les tranches d'impôt sur le
revenu avec le même enthousiasme que le
chien il a eu des propos modérés et
enthousiaste j'aurais aussi des propos
modérés enthousiastes je rappelle juste
que ceux qui travaillent en aura le bol
de payer toujours plus d'impôts ils en
ont assez et je pense que la coupe est
pleine pour eux il redoute une grande
sociale et bien moi je redoute une
gronde de tous ceux qui travaillent et
qui en ont assez travaillé pour le droit
de police et qui trouve qu'on leur prend
trop alors me dire mais c'est étrange
les plus élevées enfin je rappelle que
notre pays 10% des contribuables payent
70% de l'impôt sur le revenu donc si
vous voulez leur expliquer que quand il
y a de l'inflation on leur pique leur
argent je pense que vous préparez des
jours difficiles avec les classes
moyennes
je rappelle que dans notre pays quand on
parle de révolution d'agitation sociale
souvent ce sont les classes moyennes qui
ont refusé que on leur prenne trop et
qu'on ne respecte pas leur travail et
qu'on ne respecte pas leur engagement au
service du pays donc oui je maintiens
qu'avoir indexé le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu sur l'inflation c'est
simplement protégé ce qui travaille et
que c'est une décision juste pour les
classes moyennes enfin sur la question
la taxation c'est pas une question
anodine parce que nos compatriotes
légitimement disent ben nous on va être
bien contribution
les collectivités vont être mises à
contribution l'État va être bien
contribution c'est normal que les
entreprises qui font des bénéfices liés
uniquement à la flambée des prix paye
ils ont raison
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça la
preuve j'en récupère 19 milliards
l'année prochaine c'est quand même pas
rien bien sûr qu'il faut que les
entreprises qui font des rentes payent
elles payent et elle paieront soit par
le mécanisme de marché que je viens
d'indiquer soit on contribuant
directement quant total fait une remise
de 20 centimes d'euros à la pompe ça va
directement la poche des Français ça
coûte un demi milliards d'euros au total
quand CMA CGM baisse le prix de ces
containers ça va directement dans la
poche des PME quand les banques
s'engagent à plafonner à 2%
l'augmentation des tarifs bancaires ça
va directement dans la poche du
compatriotes et quand il s'engage à
réduire des frais bancaires pour les
plus modestes de 3 euros par mois à 1
euro par mois là aussi il participe et
c'est très bien donc bien sûr que nous
voulons que l'argent des rentes aille
dans la poche des Français et nous le
faisons à hauteur de plusieurs milliards
d'euros je Clio aucune ambiguïté
là-dessus en revanche je veux redire que
derrière ce terme très séduisant
de taxation exceptionnelle sur les super
profits se cache en réalité une taxation
permanente sur tous les profits de
toutes les entreprises de CAC 40 et
d'ailleurs certains d'entre vous l'ont
dit comme à l'Assemblée nationale de
manière très claire moi j'ai regardé la
proposition de la nups attentivement
bien entendu c'est bon c'est mon travail
dans les propositions des oppositions
qu'est-ce que j'ai vu la nupaisse
propose de taxer toute entreprise dans
le résultat fiscal 2023 serait
supérieure de 25% à la moyenne des
résultats 2017 2019 il y a 5 ans donc ça
veut dire que toute entreprise
dont les profits ont augmenté de 25% sur
5 ans ce qui peut arriver pour beaucoup
d'entreprises sera taxée autrement dit
dès que vous faites des profits vous
êtes taxés autrement dit dès que vous
réussissez vous êtes taxé bien c'est
contre cette maladie française que je me
bats depuis des années parce qu'on
commence par taxer soi-disant les plus
grandes entreprises et on finit par
taxer le profit de toutes les
entreprises sans exception PME comprise
donc ça n'est pas une taxation chez
Super profit c'est une taxation sur les
profits tout court enfin on me dit c'est
exceptionnel ah non c'est pas
exceptionnel puisque vous proposez que
cela dure jusqu'en 2025
c'est pas exceptionnel du tout c'est
permanent et puis bon courage à la
majorité de 2025 qui voudra revenir
ensuite sur cette taxation c'est comme
la taxation exceptionnelle sur les
salaires elle a été mise en place en
2009 ou 2010 c'est de l'exceptionnel qui
dure en général en France en matière de
taxation est toujours en place
donc c'est bien pour cela aussi que je
dis que ce n'est pas la bonne solution
que je préfère la solution européenne
qui prévoit que uniquement pour les
énergéticiens et pas pour toutes les
entreprises uniquement sur 2022 on est
un prélèvement qui soit de 20% lorsque
le résultat de 20% supérieur à celui de
2019-2021 et pas 2017 sur le résultat de
2022 une fois encore pour un seul
secteur sur la période de temps la plus
proche et pour la seule année 2022 ça ça
me paraît un dispositif beaucoup plus
raisonnable vous le voyez c'est un débat
qui mérite d'être poussé jusqu'au bout
pour chacun dévoile la réalité de ses
ambitions et la réalité de ses
intentions en matière de fiscalité
merci Gabriel Attal je vais faire le
même effort de concision que Bruno Le
Maire et m'attacher à répondre donc
essentiellement aux questions qui ont
porté sur le sujet des collectivités
locales c'est beaucoup revenu sur
d'autres sujets on pourra revenir
plus directement après notamment sur les
questions de forêt où je pense qu'il y a
effectivement des propositions
intéressantes on va renforcer le défi
forêt c'est ce que j'ai annoncé mais sur
votre proposition qui est fait je pense
qu'on peut regarder un certain nombre de
choses sur la situation des
collectivités locales
afin 2021 il y avait une situation très
bonne au niveau global notamment du fait
d'un transfert important de l'État aux
collectivités locales pendant la crise
sanitaire 10 milliards d'euros et de
d'un soutien indirect avec des dépenses
de l'État qui ont évité des dépenses
supplémentaires aux collectivités
locales le quoi qu'il en coûte l'État
c'est endetté mais c'est des dépenses
évitées pour les collectivités locales
si on n'a pas fait le poids qu'il en
coûte les dépenses sociales des
collectivités auraient explosé du fait
des millions de Français qui se sera
retrouvés sans emploi les dépenses pour
certaines collectivités en matière
économiques pour soutenir des
entreprises aurait là aussi exploser sur
2022 à l'évidence la photo est plus
floue parce qu'il y a des dépenses
supplémentaires un pack du point
d'indice augmentation des prix de
l'énergie de l'alimentation qui ont un
impact mais il y a aussi des recettes
qui augmentent et qui continuent
d'augmenter
fiscalité locale foncière augmente du
fait de l'inflation il y a par ailleurs
des collectivités qui ont décidé
d'augmenter leur taux les recettes de
TVA augmentent aussi j'ai fait une
annonce ce matin au Comité des finances
locales qui va faire très plaisir aux
régions au département aux interco et à
la ville de Paris qui ont chacune une
fraction de TVA on avait annoncé pour
ses collectivités au mois de mars
dernier une augmentation des recettes de
TVA sur 2022 de
2,89%. on vient de réévaluer les
recettes sur 2022 du fait de
l'augmentation des recettes de TVA au
niveau national finalement ça sera 9,6%.
c'est plus de trois fois plus que ce que
les collectivités attendaient très
concrètement ça veut dire un milliard en
plus pour les régions verser le 20
octobre 1 milliard en plus pour les
départements verser le 20 octobre et 500
millions en plus pour les interco et la
ville de Paris versés également sur le
12e du mois d'octobre fiscalité foncière
va augmenter aussi en fin d'année pour
les communes avec des hausses de taux
donc ce que je dis encore une fois c'est
que évidemment ne va pas bien pour tout
le monde mais il y a des recettes c'est
un fait qui sur 2022 ont progressé au
global deux fois plus vite que
l'inflation pour autant il y a des
collectivités qui sont particulièrement
fragilisés notamment les communes qui
assument les charges de centralité avec
qui sont beaucoup plus impactés par
l'inflation c'est celle-là qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à accompagner et c'est pour
ça que le filet de sécurité a été adopté
cet été et je veux vraiment remercier
les sénateurs qui ont enrichi le
dispositif venu de l'Assemblée nationale
il y a une belle logique transpartisane
autour de dispositif pour l'instant les
collectivités par définition ne le voit
pas puisque les premiers acomptes n'ont
pas encore été versés le décret sera
pris dans les prochains jours prochains
jours on est en train d'ajouter les DSP
dedans puisqu'il y a des choses qui
n'étaient pas claires on veut vraiment
que les choses soient claires avant de
le lancer et immédiatement communiquera
auprès des collectivités on aura besoin
de vous mais on va aussi demander au
service de l'État d'aller proactivement
voir les collectivités les plus
fragilisées pour leur faire connaître le
dispositif et les premiers acomptes
seront versés au mois de novembre pour
les collectivités je le dis qui sont
éligibles on estime que 25% des communes
leçons avec les deux critères
c'est une prise en charge jusqu'à 70% de
l'augmentation des dépenses d'énergie ou
d'alimentation et jusqu'à 50% de
l'augmentation des dépenses de masse
salariale liés à la hausse du point du
point d'indice on va la question qui
était posée sur est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous prévoyez pour 2023 c'est vrai qu'on
ne prévoit pas d'exclation de la DGF à
l'inflation parce que ça serait
irréaliste pour des raisons financières
et moi je me souviens que les coupes
massives de DGF sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande ont notamment été
justifié à l'époque c'était les
arguments qui étaient utilisés par le
fait que la DGF avait été indexée les
années précédentes sur l'inflation et
que donc il y avait une dérive et qu'il
fallait rééquilibrer en coupant dans les
dotations parce que pendant des années
une indexation sur l'inflation et sur la
croissance d'ailleurs elle est fortement
augmentée et je disais ce matin à
Monsieur Laignel au CFL qui disait bah
oui c'était mieux quand la DGF était
indexée sur l'inflation et sur la
croissance que si dans quelques années
j'en sais rien notre pays était amené à
entrer dans une phase de récession
j'imagine assez mal que les
collectivités acceptent à ce moment-là
qu'on leur retire de la DGF sous
prétexte qu'on est en récession donc
le jeu c'est d'accompagner avec le filet
de sécurité celle qui en ont le plus
besoin parce que c'est nos marges de
manœuvre donc on est ouvert pour 2023 à
revoir un dispositif de filet de
sécurité et d'ailleurs on pourra avoir
le retour d'expérience de la mise en
oeuvre de celui-là de celui de 2022 pour
l'adapter deuxième chose je le disais
tout à l'heure et je réponds ici à la
question de Christine Labarde oui on va
adapter le texte qui vous est transmis
aujourd'hui c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a
fait de la concertation c'est vrai que
ça n'a pas eu le temps de le mettre dans
le texte initial précisément parce que
l'idée est née des dialogues de Bercy
nous allons abonder la DSU et la DSR de
210 millions d'euros très concrètement
c'est 90 millions d'euros sur la DSU 90
millions sur la DSR 30 millions pour les
intercos si on ne faisait pas ça du fait
des règles de la péréquation deux tiers
des communes verraient leur DGF baisser
l'an prochain alors même qu'on a une
enveloppe globale qui est stable qui a
été sanctuarisée depuis 2017 du fait de
la péréquation deux tiers des communes
verraient leur DGF BC et donc le fait
d'abonder des su et des SR et pour les
intercos fait que 70% des communes
verront leur DGF augmenter l'an prochain
c'est une garantie ça a été qualifié
d'historique y compris par des
spécialistes du sujet puisqu'on a bon
l'enveloppe normée justement pour que la
dotation forfaitaire ne soit pas
impactée et on réfléchit par la même à
renforcer la DSR péréquation et donc sur
ce sujet on va continuer à avancer ça
c'était sur le premier sujet deuxième
sujet qui a été abordé
actualisation des valeurs locatives
est-ce que les commissions doivent
continuer à travailler c'est Monsieur
maison qui demandaient oui c'est utile
ce travail il est utile ne serait-ce que
parce que les premières remontées qui
ont eu lieu des commissions
départementales nous ont permis de faire
une forme de synthèse et de se dire
qu'il fallait suspendre l'application
est-ce que dans ce qui est remonter la
synthèse de ce qui a monté des
commissions départementales on se
retrouve avec plus 40% de fiscalité pour
les commerces de centre-ville moins 40%
pour les hypermarchés de périphérie et
quand bien même on a appliqué un certain
nombre de mesures il y a plein d'idées
toujours à Bercy on a fait un
plafonnement un planchonnement j'ai
découvert ça planchaînement un lissage
etc on est arrivé toujours on arrivait
on arrivait toujours à on arrivait
toujours à plus 15% pour le centre-ville
moins 15% pour la périphérie donc on
suspense c'est aussi l'intérêt des
dialogues de Bercy et pour répondre très
concrètement à la question tant qu'on
restera sur un système qui est basé sur
les valeurs locatives par définition la
valeur locative au mètre carré en
centre-ville elle vaut plus que celle en
périphérie donc moi ce que je dis c'est
qu'il faut probablement réinterroger le
modèle et les critères certains disent
faut aller sur la valeur vénale d'autres
disent le chiffre d'affaires au mètre
carré sur les dernières années je pense
que là dessus il y a un beau sujet de
débat et de travail tous ensemble pour
trouver un système qui est plus efficace
et qui ne pénalise pas l'activité
économique en centre-ville parce que au
contraire on veut dynamiser les centres
villes donc très ouvert pour travailler
avec vous sur ce sujet là sur la
compensation de la CVAE par une fraction
de TVA par rapport à ce qui est dit tout
à l'heure la CVE était dynamique enfin
la fraction TVA est plus dynamique que
la CVE sur les dernières années la TVA
les recettes de TVA en plus progressé
que les recettes de TVA donc c'est mieux
pour les collectivités
et par ailleurs la fraction de TVA est
moins volatile parce que la réalité
c'est que la recette de CV pour une
collectivité ça varie beaucoup selon les
années l'exemple le plus édifiant je
sais pas si je l'ai cité tout à l'heure
c'est pour les collectivités qui ont un
réacteur nucléaire à l'arrêt pour
maintenant en ce moment prenez la
commune de Civaux dans la Vienne cette
année ils ont 3 millions 8 de ces VAE
parce qu'ils avaient leur réacteur
nucléaire qui marchait l'an prochain ils
auront 53000 euros on passe de 3
millions 8 à 53000 avec le système qu'on
propose suppression de la CVE et
compensation par définition aucune
commune ne pourra voir ses VAE baisser à
l'avenir au milieu elle sera stable et
si elle a une activité économique elle
augmentera
ça ressemble être une garantie
intéressante pardon je vais essayer
d'aller vite taxe d'aménagement sur ce
sujet là aussi il y a une alerte dans
les dialogues de Bercy il était demandé
aux collectivités de rendre une
délibération avant le premier octobre
pour le partage avec les EPCI et donc
suite à cette alerte que vous nous avez
formulé on a donné un délai
supplémentaire jusqu'au 31 décembre
toutes les collectivités sont pas encore
au courant que c'est le cas donc c'est
pas mal de passer le message si vous
pouvez nous aider à relayer sur le sujet
taxe de séjour moi je suis toujours
ouvert on est toujours ouvert à regarder
les choses mais je pense qu'il faut se
poser les bonnes questions sur la
manière d'équilibrer des budgets taxe de
séjour ça me semble pas être le moyen
d'équilibrer durablement un budget et je
pense qu'il faut faire attention aux
solutions de court terme faire rentrer
plus d'argent sur une année qui pénalise
sur le long terme faire chuter
l'activité touristique dans la ville
capitale c'est un peu la même histoire
désolé mais que sur les loyers
capitalisés c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu
mettre fin à ce système de fuite en
avant parce que on fait venir des
recettes de court terme sur l'année
haine mais en même temps on engage la
ville sur des dépenses pour les années à
venir donc nous pour des collectivités
pour équilibrer leur budget et notamment
celle qui était citées tout à l'heure
c'est vrai qu'on trouve que
l'application des 35 heures pour les
fonctionnaires ça serait plus efficace
que de faire entrer des recettes
supplémentaires en allant taxer les
touristes voilà déjà appliqué les 35
heures c'est bien et donc sur ce sujet
là je pense qu'il y a encore des marges
de progrès oui enfin bon c'est des
contournements qui sont encore là je
termine sur le fond de transition
sauf si voilà mais sur le fond vert sur
le fond vert il y a un travail qui est
mené par Christophe bechut Caroline
cailleux sur ce sujet là pour définir
les meilleurs modalités nous on met
l'argent ensuite c'est eux qui
définissent les critères simplement je
peux vous dire deux choses en tout cas
moi c'est ce que j'ai remonté à mes
collègues c'est un essayer de sortir de
cette logique d'appel à projet parce que
c'est un coup d'entrée trop important
pour les collectivités voilà et deux
déconcentrer au maximum le fond pour que
l'interlocuteur préfère puisse être
celui des collectivités voilà c'est mes
deux c'est my to sense comme on dit
c'est mes deux conseils que j'ai donné à
mes collègues qui sont aussi des
remontés en tant que édules locales
puisque je le suis depuis 10 ans
et le Roger carotc le sait bien et donc
j'espère que ça pourra être retenu voilà
après il y avait d'autres questions mais
on aura l'occasion de d'échanger dans
les semaines à venir
bien merci Monsieur les ministres merci
de nous avoir consacré aujourd'hui du
temps c'était la rentrée de la
commission des finances vous l'avez
senti et nous aurons l'occasion nous
nous revoir bientôt pour poursuivre nos
débats merci à vous deux